[Music]
foreign
two one here we go
[Music]
foreign
come on
[Music]
let's go
foreign
[Music]
thank you
forever
[Music]
come on
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
myself hello everyone this is your daily
dose of Internet
I win
[Music]
what's good Turtle Squad it's your boy
[Applause]
wow
I'm gonna win this thing oh baby
he has to move his brown man whoa whoa
you could do that I can't move your
crown man like that
they have this chest rabbit that's just
terrible oh
welcome to pawn Champs ladies and
gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen we welcome you to
day five of pogchamps five the fifth
edition of this amazing tournament in
which all manner of celebrities
streamers YouTubers content creators and
others meet for some high action chess
I'm your host Grandmaster Daniel
nerdinsky alongside me today is the one
and only feed a master James Canty James
welcome to the show how are you feeling
um hi Chad are you high is POG Champs
one two three four five of them things
Paul Champs five and I'm here with my
twin brother Dania um I'm having a great
time bro it's gonna be amazing and we
got some great matches today bro
likewise James I'm genuinely super
excited this is my first pocjams
commentary of this season and I'm gonna
try to make it count and if you're not
hyped then you will be after you look at
the list of players and at the current
standings while we're at it you can see
that the standings are divided into four
groups and some mouth-watering names all
over the cross stable we've got tyler1
on an absolute Rampage we've got an xqc
who might want to consider getting your
first win of fox transfer to shown as
his daily dose of Internet who's been
getting some daily dose of nasty James
that was funny daily dose of that you
know Diane gonna come with him every
time guys Daniel with the jokes always
that was great of course but there's not
gonna be any jokes today or the joke
will be on someone if you cannot get
through today's games you got those
matches coming up it's gonna be a lot of
fun a lot of blunders and all kind of
stuff and it's just so exciting to see
who gets what today
and we've got something for everybody
we've got such a diverse palette of
different creators today let's go
through the matchups and the times if
you have any meetings planned if you
have dinner if you have a date cancel it
all because here's what we have 5 p.m
Eastern seven minutes or so from now
we've got virtually the best matchup of
the day with okay that was terrible that
was ghastly shall I see oh my God can
you just talk it's a virtual against
let's go to 6 p.m at 6 p.m I said 6 p.m
I did a thing we'll try to do a thing
against foosli oh my goodness Brian I
think I've done all of that I mean I hit
every one of them boys how do you be
coming up with these well we just gonna
almost just say Sea Dog VA okay very
very nice name there Sea Dog versus
Frank who plays a lot of Chess and you
can catch all the stuff he does online
on YouTube it's very fun to see his
reactions in there that's another
matchup uh coming up at 7 p.m Eastern
Time
indeed we've got three matchups and
these are high octane matchups
particularly in light of what happened
in the previous few days virtual is one
of the pre-tournament favorites James
he's over 1200 on chess.com he's even
been getting some IRL lessons from Anna
kramling as we take a look at him all
smiles there but he wasn't all smiles
yesterday after suffering a shock defeat
at the hands of sapnap that went into
tiebreaker not how he was looking to
continue his POG Champs and he's gonna
be looking to continue with a rebound
Victory today James absolutely he's
gonna definitely take that rebound he's
been you know he's lost before with uh
with being where he is and his nature of
his what he does trackmania of course
just being as good as he is in fact you
have to take some Elves there and that's
in anything but he's like all right cool
I gotta bounce back with one ale hey you
know I need two dubs for every one ale
there so he needs to come back I'm very
strong in this mass today and I think
he'll be uh he'll be just fine with the
energy you got to get over that and have
that right perspective going into
today's match
in detail he seems very positive uh
we're getting word that he was just
doing some puzzle rush so definitely
taking this match seriously this is what
all of the cool people do before the
match begins you don't do opening prep
you make sure that your tactics are on
point because his opponent is not just
going to roll over and die gasly has had
some incredible moments in pogchamps
thus far and James at this point after
five seasons we know better than to look
at someone's rating and make any
conclusions based off of it Gastly has
had some ghastly checkmates including
one against sapnap an Arabian mate with
a knight on A3 and the queen that's dude
there it is
bro look how hypey
oh my goodness I won mama
you ah you don't even know what to do he
doesn't know what to do all right let's
go he's screaming people in the house
right oh my goodness then you like and
then the emotion hits I won I can't
believe I won
you know every emotion you saw there
from ghastly there in a man pushes the
gas for real as American DC you DJ and
producer the man is nice especially this
EDM festivals over 1600 games played on
chess.com boy he is swinging and he's
ready let's see if he's ready today
taking lessons with uh one of the boat
test sisters Andrea the votes is so he's
getting some good uh some good uh
coaching and also with the um DJ skills
probably too as well at least trying to
help Andrea or uh Alex over there right
it's fun so that's good stuff
awesome and he's one of the most
experienced players as well I mean it's
great to see so many of these players
taking lessons taking this event
seriously because it's supposed to be a
fun event but the players really do do
their best and it's not just about the
rating the other component is how many
games have you played on chess.com how
just comfortable are you sitting in
front of tens of thousands of people
because one of the most interesting
things for me James and all of my time
watching pox Champs is watching people
like Mr Beast who have who broadcast in
front of tens of millions of people like
these people are anti-stage fright but
when they sit in front of a chessboard
the butterflies come out and a lot of
different content creators have talked
about this effect chess brings out the
butterflies in your stomach so it's
important to get chess specific
experience because your brain does crazy
things to you when you're playing in
front of a crowd yeah it's crazy right I
mean if you think about gas the EDM
festivals if you think about how many
people at a festival you don't get any
Jitters there and I'm just chilling as
another day in the office and you get
into Fun on a chess board and you start
trembling wait which who goes first this
white gopher you don't even understand
what's going on here there's so many
things that happen obviously in chess
and of course having that right mindset
going in here trying to play and
training really training work is what it
really requires here is for you how you
get some of those Jitters out hopefully
they've been working on their game
well virtual needs are virtual needs to
get those Jitters out of his system and
he needs to do it fast because if we
look at the standings of Group B virtual
has only one point and sapnap can
probably sapnap through his next game
and still make it to the Champions
bracket
Gastly he's got five points he is very
close to the top as well yeah daily dose
let's not talk about him for now I think
he's probably making his daily dose
right now this is only virtual second
match though James so
he needs to rebound and he needs to do
it now yeah of course you need that
rebound near me especially if you've
seen yourself on the leaderboard and
you're watching and you're just waiting
for your game to start of course A lot
of people do watch the Streamlight
tattoo is what we're true May having one
I'm like oh you know what I need to win
I need I need this win now I need it
right now I don't like how I look on the
standing at least I'm not at the bottom
there gassy is ready to go you can say
just focus face look at him Focus
sitting on the couch getting his mind
together getting his mind right how are
we gonna do this Zen moment
and we should add this is ghastly's last
match so yes he's four points ahead but
virtual has one more match after this so
This Could Be decisive virtual wins this
one and then he wins his next match he
could make it into the top two in the
top two in each group Advance the
Champions bracket how do you win a match
you may ask well you need to win a best
of two competition the players can test
two games with a Time control of 10
minutes and a 5 Second increment per
move that means every move you make five
additional seconds get added to your
clock versus one and a half points wins
the match and in the event of a 1-1 Time
the players draw both games or more
likely if one player wins a game a piece
then there is a fast time control
tiebreaker uh time control of three
minutes with a five second increment to
decide the winner that would be an
Armageddon game James and these
Armageddon games some of the most
interesting high octane action that we
get in case the players needed to get
any more nervous yeah worse I mean that
I've seen it watching Paul Champs just
here and I'm seeing I'm sure Chad seen
it too some of the craziest tiebreakers
we've ever seen right now of course
there have been some two o's but man
some of those tie Breakers is like whoa
how did this happen blunders everywhere
nil biting right it's just crazy people
sweating and like oh my goodness and
hyperventilating to make sure you know
that we can get to this next round here
as you see on the screen the boys are
ready ghastly and virtual we're off E4
all right hey you know we you know it's
nice right now it's good
so far so good and look at that a perk
trotted out by Gastly I like that G6
clearly some preparation not just a
random first move this is the proper way
to play the perk and we've transposed to
a king's Indian haven't we oh
well me and my twin brother Dania here
already hype okay King's Indian defense
is uh it's just op chat okay it's just
op there's nothing else to say about it
the king's Indian defense we both got
videos on YouTube about this and it held
a very special place in our h3k ID what
do you know about this H3 this Theory
this is like watching this is
professional chess James H3 is not a
move that you see generally at anything
other than a Grand Master Level if I saw
the first six moves of this game without
seeing the opponents I would I'm not a
betting man but I would put some money
on this being two over two thousand
rated players great to see some opening
preparation in action
I would actually be a little annoyed in
fact H3 is one of the Annoying lines you
can face
um in as the K as we can add you players
you see H3 you're supposed to go G4 and
the C6 move is a very flexible one sort
of you know with the finchetto variation
of G3 Bishop G2 stuff so let's see what
happens Queen D2 you might be going
Queen side
he might be trying to go Queen side on
this one what do you think
absolutely and I just wanted to come
back for a second H3 and mention that
it's a very instructive move for newer
players because it doesn't have that
flashy appeal of you know a bishop H6 or
an H4 but it stops the knight from
coming to G4 so it makes sure these
pieces are safe and there are some crazy
lines in the H3 King's Indian where the
Knight is developed to F3 and then
dropped back to H2 and then moved toward
G4 but here you see a pawn landing on G4
virtual continuing to demonstrate good
knowledge of typical ideas but ghastly
starting to stumble a little bit two
moves with this queen there James
yeah he definitely but look I I'm
impressed by virtual right now like oh
of course I mean he's following what
you're supposed to do Knight G2 E2 H3 G4
Knight goes to G3 you sakino F5 Brodus I
mean if he does this like yo hey we're
about to getting checked do we do fair
play check on these boys okay virtue is
definitely playing uh some very nice
stuff here now the king's Indian is
always obviously yeah so we still have
so many things we can do here but he's
got to be careful I mean him meaning God
so you got to get your pieces out bro
gotta get some development going here
you absolutely do these minor pieces are
rearing to go and White's probably going
to continue his kingside campaign but
you've also got to be really careful not
to blunder Knight F6 takes E4 and as I
say that virtual playing F3 let's look
into his head a little bit how is he
thinking about this position let's tune
into his stream this I think I should
play this move
[Music]
very stable
this is stable
I mean meditative silence James that's
the way we like it see track of squares
you can hear the background to the cloud
the music playing that's great
if you ever develops the bishop
okay so he doesn't I didn't know that
said the bishop just kidding that's
about how I draw my arrows
um
push the Deep D5 James
he's got some thoughts here
let me try to think about this
okay
that seems a lot more natural to push
this than let him capture here and
capture back and these are weak yeah
on the right side closed down make sure
black position is fighting on granite oh
good
I do like the Practical D5 move here
please
release it releases
do it for now do it
let's put this do it there it is oh my
goodness I'm also playing a bit slow but
I'm just being very methodical here
methodical is good but gotta keep an eye
on the clock eight minutes still plenty
of time James I have to admit to you and
to the people in chat When anybody
hovers a piece over a square it gives me
terrible flashbacks because Charlie also
known as moist critical he would do that
for minutes at it he would hover a piece
over the right move which makes it all
the more infuriating and then retract it
with 30 seconds on the clock and blunder
a piece nah let's just do this queen
hang move that looked good and then hang
his Queen and then push the SpongeBob
noise button wow SpongeBob fail wow
C5 though I probably would have
refrained from that move I think
virtual was afraid of black taking on C4
but that would have actually helped
white developed his develop his light
Square bishop and now Gastly should play
B6 and open up the queen side otherwise
White's gonna get this H Pawn rolling
and this could be Checkmate before you
can say one two three one two three
check me oh my goodness yes no sorry I
sound like he sneezes Checkmate bro so
an E6 has been player locked up
everything 92 developing and immediately
it goes to Black here but I mean of
course I'm looking at p6p5 as you said
open things up I mean really in the
opening I always figure out the just the
the the the
um I found it every opening is like the
same in a certain situation which it is
is you have to get your pieces out guys
you just have to get them off of the
back Rank and if you can get the Knight
maybe to A6 and C7 and move to B5 move
the Rook over to B8 you just need to get
pieces going F6 I like this breakdown
what do you think I like this brackets
the it's the next best thing and I think
virtual just didn't realize on the
previous move how close he is to opening
up the H file and delivering mate it's
literally three moves h4h5 takes black
has to recapture and you play Bishop H6
instead he's focusing on his development
and I think he should play F4 keep the
tension don't give blacks pieces the
activity that they need and if the
Center opens up and you get a bunch of
pandemonium the black's Queen will
really start to make her presence felt
virtual the slower player here to start
things off I think he's probably
deciding between e takes F6 and F4 James
but he's got to be a little more crisp
he's got six and a half minutes or only
12 moves in and the more complex part of
the game is definitely still ahead yeah
of course the middle game right the
middle game is where I think even Magnus
likes that Magnus Carlson with the light
oh I'll just play anything but I want to
beat you middle game in game right here
these type of things especially in
King's Indian you know King's Indian
aficianos right all you people in the
chat if you're like hey ID raise your
hand put it in the chat we love you
because me and Daniel love kid too as
well so we are playing favoritism here
but you do have to actually uh open up
the game kid's get very wild in the
middle games so B6 B5 looks good things
like this but again you gotta get those
pieces off the back rank here gas
I think we're likely to get a trade on
E5 the f file is going to open but
there's really nothing on that app file
for black
and for virtual he's running out of
ideas he is eventually going to stumble
on this h4h5 concept I just I feel
worried because I think ghastly's not
looking at the queen side but if he
plays V6 right now I am taking my hat
off and I'm not even wearing a hat wow
that's crazy you are wearing a hat
though actually I didn't notice that one
I said that take it off James that's
crazy
you've got headphones Todd you're good
yeah yeah you can go to my Instagram
Instagram thanks for the follow V6 has
been played by the way it's on the board
Dania it's on the board
that actually shows pretty deep
understanding why is B6 such a good move
why are we making a big deal out of it
because White's kind of bitten off more
than he can chew in the center so white
has to take black takes back and then
the C Pawn steps forward to C5 and we
know that in the king's Indian White
gets a bigger share of the center but
with a big Center comes a big
responsibility and if that Center starts
to crumble and collapse there will be
hell to pay and look at this it's like
inside attack versus all of Black's
pawns we're gonna get some crazy action
in the next few moves I'm taking kid all
day of course it's just I have to okay
he's Indian there it is something's
wrong what's the problem
there it is I take C5 and we live
that night where is it not going right
uh-oh oh we've got our first queen
thread of the day
sorry throwing them Haymakers that's
what gasly doing right now on the board
with some King's Indian let's go Knight
and three very strong nice C4 is coming
and here we are a classic kid bites
another one he gets another one now of
course game's not over but definitely
this is a very tough position to get out
of you might have to Castle Queen side
allow Knight C4 play Queen B3 Bishop D4
get him off though
we have to get it inside look if he
misses Knight F3 I'm leaving the
commentary Booth can we get Gastly
stream up here he's been playing Amazing
so far oh no
oh pain Panic pain
moments oh James can we get some F's in
the chat we need silence right now in
the chat
my goodness he was a good man
and he moved the piece too it's not like
he made a move on a different side of
the board he missed it he knew that that
piece had to move oh and now he's got to
avoid blundering the Knight he does have
the move E5 opening up the bishop which
will guard the Knight
okay he is talking
any blocks
yeah that won't hurt Chad everybody in
the chat like let's go Gastly go ghastly
and then he ran out of gas
he ran out of gasly yes he ran out of
gasoline right there Chad whoa this is
uh I mean this is Paul Champs five right
welcome to Paul Champs 5 chat now of
course there are going to be uh
obviously some more chances here but I
think an initiative seems like it may be
taking a turnier as uh I think gassy
feels like he's defending now
yeah virtual has given up two pawns but
first of all he still has his Queen on
the board if he plays the move H5 right
now Black's King
starts to feel Mighty uncomfortable the
two pawns aren't going to make a
difference if White's delivering
Checkmate down the H5 and big Kudos I
think virtual sense is the moment to
take the initiative as you put it man
he's like besides I mean like
this is like really against the ELO game
because it's a high level but then you
like wait Knight F3 check into the game
but then it didn't didn't he play a high
level move like H5 which is very high
level here you take you play Rook G1 or
you even bringing the queen over to H4
Castle Queen side Knight F4 he all these
ideas obviously but it starts with H5
nice understanding
I don't think virtual just buys facial
expression realizes what a catastrophe
could have endured just a couple seconds
ago I think in chess ignorance is bliss
although maybe realizing it will make
him even happier because now he feels
motivated to make that Queen work for
him speaking of guessing maybe we can
tune in and watch some more of his logic
as
that black king is getting more and more
wide open this is turning around
here's Gastly or virtual wow okay so
tape here
King's gonna try to escape probably
[Music]
isn't that better to play here
the king is still pinned to the Knight
I think so
this looks very good opening The
Bishop's diagonal as well
getting that into the attack I like this
move
I do like this move but okay I like this
he might think after this that he can
play this the music makes me feel like
I'm like Lobby of a boutique hair salon
or something a king going here would
need to get a discovery check so no
so here
I'm gonna play here
[Music]
yeah our soul doesn't look good
I think this is a bait I'm gonna play
this great move
I was a bit worried because that square
will be taken but I still have Rook Jack
and so I should be fine
yeah sounds like fun all right
I could just take the pawn to my feet no
time his time's getting low I'm am I am
getting very track looks very worried
about his time half the time for
gasoline gas has half the time more
it's impressive that he's seen E5
where's the closest material he has a
lot more materials that
and we're back to the game and gasly
gets his night out but Gastly is just
not sensing what's going on on the king
side and now Knight takes H5 is an
immediate killer
yeah you have to have the sense of
awareness of course chat or at least
defense right you just wanna one thing
that we do not teach enough of I think
in chess is the defense part of course
we love to attack and we love to go at
our opponent here but the defense is
just as important sometimes even more I
mean karpov was very famous for this
obviously but the defense right defense
defense wins championships not and chess
is different though but you do need to
defend because uh his King is weak your
King's weak you have to notice it you
have to look for defensive and creative
ways to probably do so maybe it might be
to D7 much better move here let's see is
virtual gonna play Knight takes H5
I think Knight A6 is a very
understandable move
um given how Gastly has played before
and he's played a very impressive game
but the reason he played B6 was to
create a weakness on C5 and newer
players sometimes struggle to adapt to
the new set of circumstances and they
they persist in their plan sometimes a
little bit too long and this is a good
example of that where as you said
defense over everything it was most
important to get this King to safety but
Gastly is still looking at that C5 pawn
and kind of you know chomping up a bit I
think after Knight takes H5 check that
will be a serious cold shower but two
minutes and he's played it and I think
he's got enough time to deliver
Checkmate here it takes H5 and we live
we gonna have to be very careful here
now of course problem is you have to
finish it which I don't think he's gonna
have more of a problem of finishing it
now unless there's a king h8 you're
gonna have to play Knight takes F6 here
which you have to see the king anywhere
else there's a lot of checks so h8
Knight F6 I mean it's just GG everywhere
but but he might go somewhere like
foreign
it's not just a minor piece that you're
losing you're also losing The Rook but
will virtual see this check on G7 that
virtually wins the game on the spot it
forces the king to D7 and then you can
just take the rook and you're up a
kingdom and a horse literally
you can see a little bit in ghastly's
face here he can understand the little
bite of the lip there you have and of
course the lip thing yep it happens it
definitely happens here he understands I
am not in a good position anything can't
happen though and he can't and will
happen but his Knight D7 going to be
played now virtual very impressive
through the opening of course he
definitely blundered Knight F3 check but
other than that everything else of
course has he got the attack going he
found Queen takes F6 here he found H5
and Knight F4 and Knight H5 he'll be
able to probably find Knight G7 here
followed by Queen f8 if not something
crazy gonna happen because yeah there it
is yeah Richard was playing out of his
mind now
and queen takes f8 actually threatens a
Checkmate in one I think I'm afraid the
ghastly might be tempted by D4 he might
see the pin against oh he didn't take
the Rook but okay this is still winning
if he moves the queen over to D6 you can
kind of re-fork The Rook although that
does help black get his King to a
relatively safer square and the only
reason that's pertinent James is because
of the time in White's clock you don't
want to mess around here you've got 90
seconds and virtual hasn't shown an
ability to play instantly thus far
that's what might he might need with
only a five second increment I remind
you oh you know what I did forget about
that clock of course as you just you
know crushed in the game but then you
clock and he's really getting low on the
clock here anything happens especially
when you're in time trouble check happen
King has to go to B7 he might take out
the Rope but he's not moving fast he's
not moving fast
he could take the Knight first and I
think that might be what he's
contemplating or maybe even a check on
E7
or he thinks that ghastly is baiting him
somehow maybe he's worried that the
bishop will move out of the way but it's
so important that the king is on a dark
Square were it on a light Square the
bishop would have been able to move out
with check now if the bishop moves out
Queen drops back no problem at all
yeah Queen Seven second could be nice
now we have to figure out what are we
going to do here from Gastly man your
guess is as good as mine my guy maybe
Knight takes C5 and just go for the flag
here of course as we uh have and it
definitely is one of the best flaggers
on the planet here Daniel he will flag
you with a king versus King right in the
position if chess.com did not stop it at
the draw there so just let you know the
man has a nasty technique very scary
very scary so you have to flag you have
to use uh something here move fast try
to make good moves and hope for the best
here I'm like the guy in the in the gym
who keeps taking shots when they've
Turned the Lights Off it's king versus
King and I just continue moving backing
around and moving my King around and
certainly I went I fly grandma like bro
of course he's special narrative he's
wrestling bro there it is he's here but
that's how you get that you know 3 300
bullet rating
they do it you know part of it is uh you
got to have at least a hundred thousand
points extra ELO and flagging and then
everything else in between that's hard I
was gonna say I was maybe I should have
warned him I was gonna say just don't
take on C5 with the queen oh oh my gosh
virtual could have won that Queen by
taking the Knight with check he's still
completely winning though so oh and I
think yeah the wheels are coming off
completely
oh look at that yeah we have some some
adult language there oh my goodness from
gassy hitting the laptop it looks like
and you see the camera Shake but he's uh
he if he moves quickly I mean okay could
oh no oh my goodness no all of the
pieces are coming out and this is the
classic scenario this is always what
happens right when you make one big
blunder you're tilted and you just lose
control over your moves you just stop
thinking properly and all of the pieces
disappear chess is brutal yeah he just
lost everything a head shake there
breathe it hurts oh man and he's hands
on the face so you can see all the Emoji
coming out now and gas I mean virtual is
just so chill he didn't yeah but okay
yeah exactly that's okay it's nothing
I'm in time trouble but I'm fine
there we go
he does have mate in two moves okay he's
going to go for the ladder mate here
with the Rook C7 then shift The Rook
away and deliver mate with Rook h8 this
is easy this is I think the type of mate
that almost all players are fully
comfortable with like the ladder mate is
very easy to understand just don't rush
it with Rook h8 check there we go right
oh man he play out his mind
look I'm mad if I'm ghastly I'm like oh
no this man just worked me like this in
front of all these people now of course
there was a knight F3 check there in his
class second one sportsmanship wow easy
clap there's virtual talking about I
think it is the game he doesn't have a
lot of time but he still checks came
about to begin
oh my God Anna your plan worked Anna
your plan worked
well GG well played we take the first
game
referencing referencing everybody for uh
the conceiving of this tactic
initiative versus development thanking
his coach is virtual who wins the first
game on the white side of a king's
Indian defense it was not entirely
smooth Victory and it could have gone
the other way but ghastly he has to win
this second game James he will have the
white pieces but when you've got an
opportunity to win the queen in one move
it's cut it's pretty cut and dried in
POG Champs you have to exploit the big
opportunities like the extra Queens the
mates you can't pass those up if you
want to win the tournament yeah
absolutely effective one thing yeah of
course you know coaching wise look
checks casters threats that's the
foundation every move you have to do
that's the hard part about it is doing
it every move under time pressure and
you're playing someone and then you
gotta think any other time but of course
that is the foundation and he missed a
nasty check there Knight F3 check but it
ended the game almost on the spot there
at least winning decisive material you
have to come back a little bit stronger
here especially if he has the YP system
it's crazy how quickly the game turned
after he made that blunder that was the
watershed moment in the game black was
still better even after he took on G4
instead but his King got opened up he
didn't realize how important it was to
make a defensive move and all credit to
Virtual for his attacking prowess in the
last part of the game so calm with a
minute on the clock I think I get more
nervous when I've got an a minute and a
half he had it all under control and I'm
excited to see what we get in the
opening because that was a remarkably
well played first 10 or 15 moves yeah
absolutely I mean he was like yeah
credit to the coach you know what I'm
saying and out here
bro yeah you know he was hype which is
great of course because when the
coaching works when it pays off it's
just that it's very satisfying feeling
of like oh man it worked out so of
course let's get the games up hopefully
they're starting very soon Gastly and
virtual okay with white
yep the game has just begun virtual is
going to see it reflected on his screen
momentarily and he will have the black
pieces okay the game has begun
virtual needs to wake up here he's
facing 184. he's like I've never seen
that one hmm yeah what do I do what does
this move
okay there we go
much to the relief of virtual nope no a
lot of hesitation
was that what I prepared I think he
didn't just look up at the ceiling hey
bro we got the checking yeah you ain't
doing too much he knows too much
information yeah we gotta handle him he
definitely just looked up there that was
uh uh oh yeah yeah
yeah Scotch open yeah move 17 got him
it's the scotch open this is exactly
what we practiced for exactly what we
practiced for whoa whoa that is a
novelty if I've ever seen one Knight F3
and Gastly has been in the habit of me
making a move with the right piece but
moving it in the wrong direction
hey look this is a new one I'm just I
just want to see if it's gonna work you
know what I mean it is it is uh POG
Champs chat but you know there's a book
I always like this that say you know a
beginner book in fact and this there's a
modern day version chess fundamentals I
don't know if you read that one Don I
know you read like thousands of Chess
books but here the one by Kappa Blanca
capablanca I've read Snippets of it yeah
they said one thing from it I remember
was just like uh it says refrain not
never do but refrain from moving a piece
multiple times in the opening right so
this is just very uh it's very simple
you move the piece the United three why
are we moving it to G5 let's just
develop something else first which he
should have done here he's going Knight
G5 and he's going all out he just
doesn't have he has everything on the
back rank while doing it
so the author of that book for newer
players in the chat is Jose Raul
capablanca one of the earliest world
champions you know that he was part of a
fraternity in college you see what I'm
saying
bro who knows this no I'm kidding I'm
kidding that was a pun that was a pun
wow you know what I mean I didn't even
get it dania's punsby's all over your
head someday be like dang boy that's
right bam those Kappa kappas in the chat
but uh Cava Blanca was in all
seriousness a fascinating uh character
born in Cuba he went to high school New
Jersey so he was fluent in English and
uh chess fundamentals one of the best
books really ever written in the first
half of the 20th century
yeah that was a very nice book there
absolutely man bro anything Diane said
you'd be like wow really he was that
yeah yeah because Diane would be so
knowledgeable Diana said let me find out
I'm a troll
you know the sky was once read in back
uh in the 1700s when uh you know he was
world champion for one day for one day
you'd be like all right cool yeah yeah
no you only gotta fact check it
exactly yes Jen yes yes Tanya
okay well what do we have here actually
a very nice move just now by virtual who
was not born yesterday
nor was he born the day before he spots
the threat against F7 that was ghastly's
concept but he could have done that
without playing T4 and oh this this gets
a very interesting position because the
Queens are facing each other so it's
tempting to give this check on F3 James
but if you do it too soon then the
Knight recaptures and guards the queen
so you actually have to go H6 first if
he finds that move I'll be super
impressed
oh yeah that'd be oh night night F3 and
then night f3j like Knight F3 check but
then Knight F3 right
I have three but then I have three so it
doesn't work oh six oh we just take back
but gasly he's got to put the right
piece on the right Square I don't like
that he's thinking here maybe just
double checking that C4 is undefended
don't take the queen though you'll
emerge down a minor piece
and I'd be nuts Queen takes C4 is
probably going to take the Knight unless
oh uh I guess I don't know about that
that's a new one okay okay he's there
wow okay Queen takes C4 black is the
bishop pair
oh wow
wait yeah he just dipped out but he's
here he's definitely here made him move
yeah he dipped out temporarily he's got
such a big time Advantage already that
he can afford to dip out but let's
listen into virtual again who might be
doing a little bit of overthinking
it's going through his head
so this
no okay God forbid come on bro Bishop do
you think this okay
then I can take the
I cannot take
God he's stronger is it just me yeah he
does he does I can hear that
I can hear that it accelerates the first
place but it slows down toward the end I
can play here though oh my goodness I
cannot yeah wrong thinking wrong thing
around he's thinking too much this is
what happened the first game
maybe just this safest movement up on
Twitter
virtual
no no
if here and here then here but then if
here here wow I've solved chess
and then you get made it this
if this bishop can take if here
no he can't I think it's this
okay that's basically develops the
bishop and he doesn't Wonder anything so
check and check
the problem is that the other Bishop is
just sitting on the scene
why are you taking my space why
Knight A6 and castles even though it's
sketch might just work
right
[Music]
I like how fast gassy moves but he does
like you gotta slow it down a little bit
and that was critical moments
I would love this one same thing as last
game Gastly is playing Amazing in the
opening uh he's making all the rifles
get my Bishop out
and it stops on you can play
okay I just gotta make a decision here
there you go yes you do
I gotta play faster I'll play this
okay that's also Black's pieces are
awkward but it's hard to exploit it it's
very unpleasant bro Mahi move is so fat
ghastly breathe breathe man it's making
me uncomfortable breathe bro we insta
moving instantly it didn't blunder but
let's go look at this and he's making
the Right Moves thus far but what
worries me is when you keep up this pace
into the middle game that's when the
blunders are a lot likelier to happen
Queen E5 threaten Checkmate or is he
gonna retract and Retreat the queen back
to d8 and with Gastly moving instantly
Queen E5 would be a great move here
right now practically his mate and he's
just moving so fast that he might
immediately miss the mate on H2
I feel like they say that the line
between genius and insanity is blurred
the line between confidence and tilt can
be hard to draw as well like is Gastly
just Uber confident well prepared or is
he tilted from the previous game or is
it both
could be a little bit of both his pieces
look nice with that Knight G5 like don't
try this at home guys it works in this
game but it may not work on yours so
definitely his pieces look good though
next time I play Hikaru entitled Tuesday
I know I know how to reverse the trend
e45
E4 Ed Knight G5 and look at him staring
at him real hard when you do it the
things you learn in POG Champs you know
what I'm saying
okay what does white do though and I
like that ghastly is taking a little bit
of a pause there's a lot of things that
you can do Knight F3 is exactly what I
was going to point out that that's crazy
you drop the Knight back but you aim at
the Knight on H6 and if virtual is alert
then I think he'll play Knight G4 in
order to avoid his kingside Pawn
structure from getting completely
crippled yeah Bishop H6 is definitely
coming here and I like to speed at
Gastly he's playing at and he's just I
mean there hasn't been any blunder you
know that of course as things go on in
the game pieces get more developed there
are mini blunders that can obviously
happen but uh so far so good for gassy
here if he wants to make take this boy
into tie breaks which is now even faster
tests than before where virtual was not
moving fast really at all Ricky and he's
that is not that loses I mean
basically win the game with Bishop G5
because the queen isn't trapped per se
black can play F6 but that would have
opened up a discovery okay Bishop H6 is
still really good that was his initial
idea so totally understand why he went
for this but he's got to follow this up
with active play Maybe Queen D4 rookie
one decent but now black can take the
night away with C6 give himself a little
bit more breathing room right quite
annoying of course C6 is going to be a
very good move you have to back the
Knight up from the center of the board
controlling the nice squares there and
you gotta probably tuck the bishop Danny
kopeck style right in the movie D5 Queen
D6 you just have to get open up the game
quickly you do have the Bishops Bishop
B5 okay all right I can capture it will
it happen
got virtual looking and still the same
it doesn't see any stress there or any
like Panic he is lower on time and his
position isn't the greatest here but he
seems to hold his composer very nice
yeah he's
always just focused on trying to find
the best move and
he's got to keep an eye on the clock at
this point Knight takes C5 Rook takes C5
that pawn C7 might fall but if I'm
ghastly I'm obviously training my eyes
on Black's King there are some ideas
involving lifting The Rook from E3 over
to G3 what I wouldn't do is take on C7
with the queen and give black the option
of training Queens because anytime the
Queens get off the board it's harder to
attack by definition so before trading
Queens first thing you want to ask
yourself is who's got the safer King and
if it's you then likely you want to keep
the Queens on the board but look at
Gastly and the energy with which he's
playing right now yeah I think you know
a lot of times a person like your your
chest style is basically how you kind of
are in life in many ways I mean you can
just know like Ashley's the EDM guy the
music festivals right so he's going to
play probably aggressive chess here
right and he actually does in fact very
aggressively the king's Indian first
game had a great position missed Knight
F3 this game he just went all out with
this novelty Knight G5 outdoor opening
and then you know it just tends to work
here he has a very nice F4 here hits the
world queen D4 coming who is this the
best the best move in the position was
Queen D4 because not only are you
threatening this Fork which is
Unstoppable but if black tries to run
with his own two feet king f8 queen h8
is Checkmate look at oh he's got made in
one Maiden one
one neither one
Queen h8 and we go to tie breaks Queen
h8 and that is this is it I feel like oh
no
but he's still completely winning and
this is the same mistake he makes he's
made in the previous game James where he
plays a move that has an intention and
he doesn't see how his opponents move
impacts what needs to be done oh my gosh
but he's still totally winning I think
he should still be able to win this game
can we get a moment of silence chat and
some apps in the chat I believe that the
momentum has changed once again I just
don't believe this is this I don't think
I see has it in them here now for some
reason
after missing that one
he finding everything
and then
when it counts
I feel like as a commentator I have to
disagree with you for the added hype I
think the deciding factor might be
Black's clock two and a half minutes and
that's true unless unless Gastly blunder
something like a knight or a queen if he
keeps up the tension he should be able
to win at the very least on the clock
yeah and but you know we had this too
but okay last game was different it was
low on the clock but I mean he was just
winning virtual was but in this game
down on the clock and I mean I have uh
three of my four pieces on the back
right with my king looking absolutely
crazy why is my king on fa here and I
don't have any shelter I could have just
kept it on E8 and Rook H4 gets out of
the way could be trapped after G3 Knight
takes H7 this boy moving so fast today
my guy actually is mad I like the energy
but he's had he has to convert
there's a beautiful mate
that happens after King E8 you give a
check on h8 drive up the king and queen
back to E5 with some gorgeous geometry
look at the Knight on H7 visualize how
it guards the f8 square but my guess is
that virtual might go the other way King
G8 and then the Knight will drop back to
F6 I love doing that James you take a
pawn and you've got the getaway driver
in place on D4 you've got safe passage
back and he's got that made into queen
h8 king E7 Queen E5 is Checkmate but he
didn't see Queen h8 mate will he see the
harder one no second mates second mate
who's looking though come on G3 you got
checks captures threads gasoline checks
next best thing
he's got it he's got it he's got it take
that Rook off the board there we go come
on bro yeah he's got this press the
button hit the buttons he says hit the
button bro hit the button that's the
resign button check
trade
take that guy on H6
all right okay minutes eight minutes on
the clock still
look at this is just Flawless technique
other than the missed mates and I'm not
being sarcastic here he's gonna go B3 oh
my gosh and take F7 you know why yeah he
definitely rampaged here but he had mini
checks I wonder how the conversion is
going to be he might just just take
everything right take everything and go
for a simple Rook roller mate or a queen
and Rook mate whatever mate I can find
here you know at this point I mean it's
good he's up on time so he should be
able to win this you should be able to
win this I believe now before after
missing that mate I was like what are we
doing everybody got silent it was
silence across the globe
C4 counter attacking the bishop but the
thing that newer players James struggle
with the most in my experience is
conversion it can be painful to watch
you know three four extra pieces or more
and I think a lot of the players in Pock
Champs they have a hard time avoiding
stalemate they have a hard time of
understanding like how they're actually
going to win they amass all these extra
pieces and then just kind of start not
doing anything and not making progress
or blundering those pieces away
and after King F6 you've got to be a
little bit careful that is a fork uh but
virtual is just too passive this game oh
goodbye oh oh he pre-moved Knight takes
d8 oh man he hi boy and then you got
mates coming everywhere check oh my God
it should be seven F6 rookie rookie
[Music]
let's go let's go
coming back
let's do that one more time one
more time
he's got a great voice
yeah it's almost like he's in the music
industry
yeah yeah that's funny that's good stuff
gas leak has been rectified and the
score is one one you know what that
means James I think everybody knows what
that means that means we are going to a
Blitz game
if virtual keeps up the pace that he's
had so far he will lose on time by move
six
that's not gonna be good you're gonna
have to speed up a lot here guys now
we're in the blitz portion really
anything goes here but he was able him
being ghastly to strike back here is
anybody's game here Diane
completely I mean I can see this going
both ways I think if virtual forces
himself to speed up from the very
beginning plays a little bit more
actively he is the stronger player but
ghastly plays with such passion such
determination and he puts so much
pressure on you because of his clock
management that this is a very effective
strategy in Blitz and bullet I mean I'm
a little bit biased
um so I'll let you take it from here
James maybe I shouldn't talk about
effective strategies in bullet but I can
see this going both ways
absolutely I mean gas Gastly if he
pushes that gas you know as fast as he
was going he could even blunder mate or
I mean he's gonna have a sizable time
advantage and be able to convert that
somewhere in the game hopefully
especially as opponent gets lower on
time accuracy pretty accurate especially
in that first game at least he was okay
for uh for um a ritual there but here
are the rules here here's the guy here's
the tie break rules what are we going
through Daniel what they got to do
so we have three minutes plus five per
move that's the time control white is
determined by the accuracy of the
previous two games which is ghastly
ghastly had the more accurate cap score
and if the game is drawn the players
swap colors but I think I'm gonna say
right now we're not going to have a draw
so we don't really have to worry about
that
let's watch the game and we have a
French defense
what are you doing oh man friends
defense this might be over in 10 moves
no of course the French is a very solid
opening if you know what you're doing
you know the plans and ideas like you
should every opening that you play no
plans and ideas over the moves to help
you remember the moves so let's see what
happened we got this French here uh
definitely the aggressive style is
ghastly with the Knight to C3 played so
far theory that is not a move that's
actually a gamut but I'm sure he didn't
mean to do that Daniel yeah I think he
might have confused what to do after
Knight D2 and Knight C3 after Knight D2
the tarash defense it's a completely
legitimate move here okay white was
supposed to take on C5 that's an early
Mistake by Gastly and I like that
virtual played something a little bit
offbeat to take Gastly out of his
comfort zone
definitely here I mean now he is a sort
of okay position here this is the French
where the pawn should be on C3 and the
Knight should be anywhere else but C3 in
fact because we can't stabilize the
center as much now she takes D4 might
have been a little bit more accurate now
we have a chance to play Knight A4 or D
take C5 here from whites but we'll see
what gassy plays remember this is Blitz
like they gotta be quick B3 oh yeah this
is
this is a gross movement
oh
well he's the problem there's two
problems you've lost a pawn but you've
also lost your Pawn chain so now you've
got another big you know serious
weakness on E5 and virtual really oh
Queen takes C5 wins
potentially a piece I guess white could
have played Bishop E3 there he takes
with the Knight which gives white a
chance I think to develop with Tempo
Bishop B5 check then you can castle and
get those pieces out of the gates Bishop
D7 so I can get rid of my bad Bishop
which is the line Square Bishop in The
Fringe Bishop D7 automatic move trade my
bad one for your good one we can just
Castle here or in allow Bishop takes B5
to happen let's see what happens he
takes gets rid of his bad Vision 96 D7
and black is totally fine in this
position
and big compliment to Virtua who has is
unrecognizably faster right he has only
spent eight seconds in the first 11
moves and ironically he's played a lot
better than he did in even the previous
two openings I think he gets in his head
sometimes and he's actually got great
fundamentals and good instincts
yeah
it might be five and we live hits the
queen gotta go somewhere let's see where
he puts it
don't have to be eight forward to C6
don't go sideways to B6 for reasons that
I will not point out
I won't hang the queen I don't think he
is he this is where he started to take
his first think
it was up a little bit of time first
time to match their queen of C6 attacks
your knight you go back buddy
are we gonna see a three-time uh very
professional three-time repetition
actually we might 94 Queen C7 1995. no
way
no way I mean virtual's got to be the
one to decline it and I would do that by
Queen C7
um okay
that's disturbing oh and Gastly goes for
it with Bishop B2 and they troll what we
don't do that around here Bishop D6
hitting H2
okay he defends it with G3 very alert
move now he can go back to B5 and
eliminate this bishop but that doesn't
really bring him that much concrete
benefit I would still do that I think it
gives white an uncontested Bishop that
move he just played again right piece
wrong Square it's been a pattern
yeah it's been a pattern here but it is
uh it's POG Champs five of course and he
also is playing much higher rated than
what it says 693 definitely played more
like pin 93 I mean at least a few
hundred points higher some of the things
he was able to find today and of course
uh you know poses some problems but
taking it to tie breaks here as the
underdog in this match here so pretty
good from ghastly here virtual having a
good position here but also still the
same on time so this is pretty level
still
I would throw an E5 start running that
pawn up the board great stuff from
virtual let's listen in because he's got
a serious shot here a couple more good
moves and he might be close to winning
here here's virtual
yeah so let's play this
stopping him from taking my knight and
getting this attack
yeah that's what he's doing
uh it will not work
inspired it will not work buddy
so definitive
it ain't gonna work not around here like
wow 24. that isn't gonna work and not
not over here bro
nah okay he attacks my my backwards Palm
that's okay
because I can now can play this move
this is the time to play it it's time to
play this move kick away the night
it still doesn't work I will just take
his Queen
whoa play Fast wait how did he plan to
do that again that's crazy
that's why I think Anna Kremlin should
have been taking lessons
sensing the backwards
it's okay
that's okay
this is also a good move now three
what was that Bishop
even up here there we go there we go
still up a pawn
okay
amazing if you want to stay on this one
but Gastly is defending well he's
pairing all the one move threats and
black is only upon up here
oh that's actually a great move but not
for the reason he thinks it is steaks
yeah
um
it's got some heat there E5 yeah B5 is
nasty ignorance would have been Bliss in
that moment but he's talking
yeah I would love to be in the room with
that yeah just the music you know what I
mean you could just sit there and just
listen you're just gonna have a great
day guys when you got his music playing
in the background
he's got a great day on the board I love
the way his pieces are coordinated he's
up 20 seconds that's not a situation
Gastly has been in and if he just keeps
his foot on the gas pedal here
then
I feel like Gastly is running out of
ideas
oh
ce1
[Music]
what he wants
what's the time looking like okay he's
getting lower
oh even though oh even which is
impressive virtual was down a lot of
time
in the last two matches two or two games
that is no clear discoveries here I mean
Bishop A3 is possible but all that
really does is trade the Bishops I think
I would maybe even consider a slow move
like A6 maybe E4 and Bishop E5 and as I
say that he plays it or gotta get your
Queen off of this diagonal he does that
Queen E3 but that allows maybe even a
knight G4 over to E5 in some cases E4 is
hanging oh he murdered his Bishop whoa
the bishop oh and he saw it he forgot
about the Knight
s on the rim are amazing Knights on A4
not as good as Knights on A2 but they're
still pretty darn good nights when the
rim are amazing this is uh Danya 2023
Daniel near ditski that's exactly right
should have listened to my sage advice
well and there it is he takes it he
finds it
this changes everything unironically
that phrase is usually used
sarcastically now white is up a bishop
wow and you can see Gastly making the
praying motion this is exactly what he
needed and now all he needs is to
convert this minor it was a little bit
scary
a good Advantage now we shall see
we shall see
thank you
[Music]
okay take that Knight off the board
what's he gonna do oh he gotta move oh
yeah he got 35 seconds that's a big big
concern yeah he got him all day he's
singing but his clock isn't singing
is that Puccini or Verity
yeah I'm gonna get up out of here I
ain't come here no I got tickets to
bizet's Carmen today but Queen E3 great
move 34 seconds
[Music]
okay that's Jurassic Park apparently
which I had no idea
I thought it was an opera
well it didn't sound right anything like
we would expect from him
so but he's whatever it takes because he
got to move now you got 20 seconds move
oh Rook D3 Rook D3 is a huge move
oh my gosh Rook D3 might turn this one
around because the queen is such an
unreliable Defender because it's easy to
attack and he sees it and he blunters
The Rook oh
he could have still kept an advantage by
taking that rook and then taking the
Rook on Y8 and he would have had a ton
of pieces for Black's Queen but and
virtual sees it no more singing
um
no way it's in help call the ambulance
but not for me oh my goodness oh god oh
man
Queen F4 to G4 and he moved his King
no but he's got 29 seconds does Gastly
it's not over it's not over he needs to
play fast and he needs to avoid
buttering his Queen back wow that was
crazy that was one of those bullet
tricks which it does only works look at
the hands on the face oh man
bro come on bro please blunder look he's
going through all the faces we all
understand we've all been there under a
minute here anything can happen
if you're a ghastly if you're virtual
play fast and open up whites King I like
that move a lot use your Rooks you can
checkmate with the two Rook so check on
E2 I check on D2 gasly is running away
with his King but
he has to win the game the queen is not
going to win on it's always the Rook too
C5 and now it took on C3 total collapse
yeah 2023 right Knights on the edge are
great
all right well no more night he's
finally gotten rid of it got rid of that
night yikes ghastly is looking to close
this one out you can tell look he's
pumped breathing breathe through it just
breathe
that's a spite check and he's played so
fast he's almost up to a full minute on
the clock now all right both actually
are closer to a minute now I'm having 20
seconds before virtual here um you can
see all the emotion on his face oh my
goodness
it's just chilling on E2
yeah
wait oh and he got it there it is ah
let's go the camera gone virtual camera
competition my friend excellent match oh
[Applause]
he thinks
oh man
wow
do I need to say anything else I guess
we need to restate that the score is two
to one as ghastly wins the tiebreaker
game in shocking fashion it took some
hanging Queens it took some crazy
turnarounds but at the end of his energy
and his passion prevails James what a
ridiculous final minute of that Blitz
game we just saw that was crazy I mean
he could have went anyway Queen G40
hunger wrote but didn't know you hunger
Rook you hang a queen no you hang a
queen and then gasly takes it it was
absolutely epic to say the least Chad is
hype we're hype about that one that was
just wild as we expected from Fall
Champs 5. and another huge win for gasly
because that was his last match of Group
B which means he actually passes sapnap
the top two finishers get into the
Champions bracket and a big blow for
virtual who only gets a point uh for
this match and it appears that sapnap is
no longer Within Reach a tragic tragic
outcome for the Norwegian streamer but
at the end of the day that's what POG
Champs is all about these turnarounds
they're normal they're just part and
parcel of matches that feature less
experienced players but huge kudos to
gasly that was great to watch that was
great to watch of course um from all the
emotion from both sides here and some
learning experiences from both sides
blunders some great moves there and we
have a winner through that which is
gassy so that's pretty good there man
that's just that's one of a few more
matches here guys wow I mean that's kind
of crazy dinosaur it's been amazing
it has indeed folks we will have an
interview with both players we will ask
their thoughts on this match and on Pock
champs as a whole we congratulate Gastly
and we will set these players up more
pogchamps five action coming up with
these two players in just a couple of
moments
the way back
[Music]
I've worked with the two players perhaps
with the best chess intuition ever
Magnus Carlsen and Michiana
this course is generally about examples
like this common knowledge that's used
on on the highest level
intuition comes from knowing a lot of
examples from having seen examples
thought about them and perhaps tried to
implement the principles but under
different circumstances having thought
about it having tried to implement it in
a way and having debated it so that's
more or less what I try to do with this
course
basically puts the foundation for
positional understanding positional
intuition you will see in in many
players
foreign
this August engage in a battle of Epic
Proportions against some of the most
Bodacious artists history hath ever seen
behold Raphael the prince of painters
doth seek a fresh Apprentice Dost thou
possess the prowess to impress him
Michelangelo a true renaissance man
painter sculptor architect and poet doc
possess a myriad of artistic talents yet
one wonders can his creative genius
translate to Brilliance upon the board
of chess
prepare thyself for a game as dramatic
as the Baroque paintings of Artemisia
gentileschi one of the most expressive
artists of the 1600s
I run out and sculptor Donatello stands
tall as one of the most important
artists of the early Renaissance his
unique blend of creativity Aesthetics
adaptability and patience maketh him a
challenging foe Lo Leonardo da Vinci
known for his artistic talents
scientific curiosity and innovative
ideas is the very embodiment of the
Renaissance he is not only among the
greatest artists to ever live but also
one of the greatest thinkers May a
fortune smile upon thee create thy
Masterpiece on chess.com cowabunga
[Music]
let's go
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to pogjams five we just saw
a scintillating matchup that was amazing
it came down to a tiebreaker Gastly
defeats virtual with a score of two to
one on the strength of that time
scramble in the Blitz game and we have
the participants of that match here for
an interview Gastly virtual it's an
honor to have you in the studio and hear
your thoughts gassy I'll start with you
congratulations first question a very
specific one at the end of that
tiebreaker game you put your queen on
pre it was hanging from then you took
Black's Queen did you do that
consciously or when you released the
queen did you realize that you had hung
it or was it was it a premeditated move
I'd like to sit here and tell you that I
was some kind of Chess genius but quite
frankly I totally blundered that and I
was like this is where virtual is going
to absolutely decimate me but I think we
were both under such a strong time
crunch and and I didn't realize it the
same way he didn't it was just like
one of those things where you know it it
was either do or die right there that
was definitely a game deciding moment
for sure and had virtual seen it dude
dude but it decimated me it would have
been KO
wow great match guys virtual your music
in the background was just like a topic
everywhere I mean so calming it was like
Zen moment like you could just you know
we needed to be in that room what were
you listening we gotta know uh there's
this great artist called Rush Garcia
might as well give them a shout out
makes orchestral music of like popular
pieces and um I really like his music so
they give me like this column that you
were talking about and I was just trying
to
be study Play Good chess and not get
flustered as as ghastly said that Blitz
game was uh something else we were both
really feeling the pressure so yeah
well Gastly you definitely were feeling
the pressure you lost the first game and
then came back with inventions in game
two you also played really fast
throughout the opening fast and
confidently was that a conscious choice
to to put pressure on virtual's clock
and what did you tell yourself to Hype
yourself up after that loss in game one
to Rebound in so strong a manner in the
second game
um so I I definitely have just been
playing enough chess to where I can move
a lot faster I do a lot of Blitz
practices and uh and bullet as well
um and I and I've always liked the idea
of like have exercising the split
decision or Split Second decision making
skill which is definitely critical in
chess especially when it comes down to a
time crunch but um after after virtual
kicked my ass I was just like all right
that was well done like I just gotta
come back you know it's uh it's just
there wasn't really any like big hype up
or anything like this it was just all
right I know why I sat down to play
today and I'm just gonna try again you
know
virtual what type of preparation did it
go in today's match you were very calm
you were also like uh you know you were
taking your time he was really thinking
the first two games but in a blitz you
like really sped it up it was very
competitive on the time there yeah it
was uh it was quite a lot of preparation
we knew uh we knew Gastly played the
king's Indian so we uh we conceived a
plan and the first couple of moves in
that first game it was like it was just
going on the recipe I I felt like I knew
everything I was gonna do
um the second game I got quite surprised
I haven't played a lot against the
scotch opening but yes they did and I
was very very sharp so I had to take a
moment to just like okay what does this
move do where am I getting checkmated
next Etc
uh and on the third game when you have
the white pieces again I thought okay
I'm not I don't want to deal with that
you play the French if you don't want to
deal with it you just play the French
and you get a stable position and it was
it was a lot easier to play that third
game but still very very sense
if I could say virtual I could tell that
you could uh you could see through my
King's Indian defense I I you you played
that really well so I got a I gotta
manipulate that a little bit and change
it up hmm
yeah so uh thank you guys
thank you guys very much that was such a
fascinating match and thanks for popping
in for the new we will let you take your
well-deserved rest
excellent thank you very much fellas
have a great day yes sir thank you
all right we've got one match in the
books big big win from Gastly we really
appreciate the players always coming in
being so gracious with their thoughts
whether they win or lose but in front of
you are the remaining two matches of the
day coming up right now we've got I did
a thing who is is he gonna do a thing
against foosli and then at 7 pm Eastern
approximately we've got Sea Dog VA
against Frank so
Canty that was only one match which is
kind of hard to believe but it was we've
only seen one match we're not even
halfway through
yeah we got more matches coming up in
fact right I did a thing and then
firstly oh we this is gonna be fun chat
so we don't know what's gonna happen
these next ones because I really didn't
know what was going to happen in the
first one so this is why I love to do a
chat and you're here watching it too as
well Donya we got another match coming
up of course we've seen these guys play
before Fuzzy's first time here it's her
first time going to be doing it uh here
playing at Paul Champs so it'll be
amazing to see her see what she can
bring to the table too as well
indeed but I did a thing we'll Spotlight
him for a bit he's a big YouTuber over
four and a half million subscriber he is
Australian
and he's also been taking lessons from
the Czar of college chess Joe Lee also
known as Joe Bruin so again really
everybody taking this seriously he's got
a pretty solid rating 825 he's played a
lot on chess.com recently so he's just a
solid stalwart player and he's been
taking lessons I think he's coming in
really well prepared James oh yeah
definitely I mean we've seen him before
he was a hype you know he's high I think
he just uh he has a lucky did you hear
about the good luck charm he had Daniel
did you see that look no tell me about
it good luck charm was a deadly
Australian spider I'm like bro what the
heck what are you doing good luck charm
you man look hey be careful you know
once you get bit or nothing crazy but
that's what he has so if he got that
spider with him that's already an
automatic red flag I'm gonna be scared
you know fight facing that guy in a
spider that's very as deadly as the one
that he has apparently he has a spider
guys you know what he's talking about
Chatham sure chat oh this is kind of
crazy
well I I heard fousey is shivering her
hands are shaking and the only thing
that's preventing all of that is the
fact that it's her second pogchamp's
appearance I actually think just
piggybacking off of what we talked about
initially that that is huge it really
helps you eliminate the butterflies in
your stomach because you've been here
before you know the procedure of course
Bruce Lee really needs no introduction a
very well-known streamer a YouTuber a
content creator a jack of all trades and
now a veteran POG Champs player so I
really think that this match can go both
ways it's really really hard to choose a
favorite here will it be the experience
level of foosli or the slightly bigger
playing strength
um of I did a thing okay firstly there
as I say again you know it's getting the
hands right chat you know what's funny
actually that is very good to do is to
stretch just like get ready get prepared
for the match of course in this day and
time so much computer work right she's
just doing the hand stretches there
getting ready like let's get to work
let's get to work here and where is work
on the board we got our sales at Carroll
Khan
carocon very popular opening at all
levels of Chess it's easy to play it's
built on solid fundamentals and I did a
thing releasing the tension early e
takes D5 is not an amazing move but it's
also not a terrible one as as long as
both sides are developing their pieces
we're not really nitpicking
yeah here is uh this is some type of oh
we can go to you know I'm like I'm
looking at transpositions here D4 and
Bishop F4 and we enjoy lava land right
but that's kind of funny here very funny
to see that actually never have seen
that transition this first time ever but
hey if there's nobody usually does ev5
D4 wave we see Bishop F4 here I mean we
don't have to give them a call after
this person that would have been insane
that would have been a transposition
to an opening that we both play the Jar
Jar Binks but instead I did a thing kind
of following the opening rules
developing nights before Bishops and
fusely saying no that Knight is not
moving again that is called a pin that's
a pin for the win and honestly she has a
very oh yeah that's already going to
damage some structure but this is some
strange stuff going on maybe you can
take there's a C3 Sicilian line after
Bishop F3 Queen df3 Knight D4 Queen D5 I
see two King D1 and then you take out D5
Knight takes Knight A1 Knight C7 King E7
98 you actually have Bishop B5 it's like
a C3 Cecilia line that happens a lot it
was really cool to see but in this
position here she backed up and did not
want to do anything unbelievable there
wow Bishop F3 was a move
yeah Bishop F5 a little bit inconsistent
so if only we could understand fousey's
motivations behind that move maybe if we
had access to her stream I think for the
next POG Champs that would be kind of a
nice touch oh wait wait a second
this yeah I'm in a castle too
I'm in a castle as well so I can do this
I can also do this I'm looking to
develop my pieces let's look at
undefended pieces my my thing is
defended here he's defended
um any attacks what's he attacking he's
attacking the Sky Bar I'm defending
there he's attacking my thing right here
defending okay we're kind of good
there's a thing on D5 that's about to be
undefended is probably just gonna be
like develop this develop development
out okay that's okay
Panic not really sure what happened
there what he took but he took something
oh God okay that's okay perfect uh well
that's okay I was gonna do this anyway
okay the range of emotions
Panic after rookie one
but that night coming out blocking the
check white can take on D5 though James
I think both players are blind to that
point on D5 here and here yeah
definitely hard to see that of course
sometimes and it's more of an advanced
tactic there but they aren't working on
it all right oh oh yeah
wait oh my goodness oh my God that's not
what I meant to do I thought that's it
putting my piece back it was here put it
here oh no
he can still let me say this
and it worked it worked it worked the
mouse slip worked
I thought I was like letting go what
just happened I don't I didn't
understand any of what just happened
fousey played Bishop C7 she was unhappy
but James in the hierarchy of mouse lips
that all of us have committed that was
not a bad one
that wasn't bad in fact the Inc was hc7
was fine it's like oh man I blundered
the game like everybody like yo you just
just take it back breathe you can take
it back and then he blundered and then
she found it and now she moved the
bishop back to B8 all the way back there
reminds me of a story I I was playing a
game over the board game it's another
Grandmaster about seven years ago
so I made a move and I got up to go to
the bathroom
so I come back from the bathroom and I
see that it's it's my move right he had
made a move while I was in the bathroom
and I thought that he had moved his King
up to from G1 to G2 I thought he made it
completely innocuous move so I wrote it
down on my score sheet and then I
immediately played the move that I had
planned because that's what I thought he
would do the moment I carried out my
move I realized that his King had
already been on G2 which means that he
had played a different move on the other
side of the board that I had not paid
attention to at all for all I knew he
could have attacked one of my pieces and
I wouldn't have noticed that turns out
that he moves a Pawn on the other side
of the board and it didn't create any
threats so I was counting my lucky stars
but for some reason foosli's moment
there
all's well that ends well but you know
sometimes Mouse slips can be a little
bit more tragic uh than that the game
did end in a draw in the end wow yeah
that's funny that is one that you got to
be careful guys OTB mouth slips in fact
that's exactly right
G4 man he's going aggressive here but he
misses some pieces here definitely were
eight piece right but of course we're
going A8 is still stuck in the on the A8
Square original Square here we need to
kick the Knight away from B5 maybe play
Queen C7 or D6
and uh convert this advances that we
have now actually foosli doesn't even
really know all the pieces name she said
like yeah this thing here and like you
know but she's playing very nice I think
she's really you know playing around
with that like oh I don't know anything
Michael starts right and then you just
get waxed you know so it is definitely
showing a little bit of strength here
Bruce Lee absolutely especially if she
plays Queen D7 that G4 Pawn is going to
get waxed and she's attacking it another
way I did a thing needs a big blunder
here he needs pressure down the E5 let's
tune into his uh side of this game
now if the man he would oh it's the
horse moves
okay I forgot Australian yes okay makes
sense that's all right okay I was like
what move I was like what horse moves
interesting because then I get my
Gnar
let's get some let's get this Rook on
there
the H square or I just bring the horses
horse over sandwich
multiple squares horse over the G5
down
live in Canberra
go in the check
can't go up then I just keep then I
promote that doesn't seem I could listen
to him all day for eight the next eight
hours yeah like yo can you can I get a
Yeah
Siri please thank you yeah
it was a Siri option or like uh GPS
Google Maps option like I did she moves
when I say he by the way look at what's
going on
massive threats on the king side this is
getting concerning
she might put it something yeah
stuff like that yeah you have to be
careful 96 is coming she does need to
get some pieces out because she actually
has everything on the background yeah
you have a piece well where is it and in
fact if you think about it that piece is
only eight kind of one piece Bruce Lee's
last fousey's last two moves caused all
of the problems first she played H6 and
allowed white to take then she pushed
her Pawn to F4 which looks innocuous but
the problem isn't that it closes the
bishop the problem is that it opens the
queen and Rook F5 I like but there are
crazy tactics here I would push the
spawn up to H7 and try to lure this King
onto a forkable square I feel like I did
a thing Mico 96 immediately though if I
have understood how the workings of his
mind correctly but we'll see 96 is very
nice H7 is very nice too with king h8
and queen F5 possible I mean oh yeah you
win the peace back after Knight F7 Ida
rookie seven that's really oh my God
that's a crazy move really taking the
Rook here yeah yeah eight seven right
eight seven King AJ queen of five and
then the rookie H7 played played very
nice do not go King G7 do not
you only have oh my goodness you have to
go h8
you have to and then
oh yeah that's a wrap that's a wrap
that's a wrap moment is silent man
foosie played very well but she just
made all these inaccuracies uh with the
with obviously opening up the king and
not developing pieces principles guys
the principles you gotta develop your
pieces oh my goodness 96 can we get a
reaction Loosely there let's see no
reaction nothing yet not yet but we're
about to see one it's a slightly Delayed
Reaction but oh no okay oh no
um she doesn't realize that that one's
the queen yet but she will she's like I
just realized it's a check yet okay no
he's
my king and queen and that's the new one
man oh no this is four he's a genius
he's a genius
he's a genius chat he's genius 100
percent
that feeling when your queen disappears
a universally
familiar pain experienced by all who
have inhabited this Earth and walked the
halls of chess.com
that one hurts
oh but it's not over I mean
and I say that with five years of
pogchamp's experience under my belt
yeah
five years
oh whoa that's already a step in the
wrong direction James White could have
taken the night with track and that
would have basically been hit the button
time Rook takes E7
was the thing she still has something
here remember she said what did she say
she was like uh
she was like oh yeah it's not Alexis
whoa got over oh yikes oh man
whoa wait why can't why take that Bishop
is that Bishop defended by like a ghost
somewhere on the chessboard
King takes
the problem is you move a muscle and
White's Queen just infiltrates like if
you move this Knight then Queen F7 is
possible if you move the other night and
D5 Falls the pieces are just too passive
to support oh Queen H no Queen H3
doesn't win The Rook but so solid C3 E3
what a Russian Schoolboy move right
there D3 what's the time looking like
time's good too this is difficult she
got the piece
play very well and then it came down
weak and that's just what happens
obviously since I was here
tough game but it's not over yet
okay yeah oh and Pinky too King G2 and
we might have two Geniuses in this game
if if I did a thing drops back to G2 and
walks into a pin on H4
or shall I say on H Fork
his Fork King F4 will be Rook f8 King G4
there is some mating okay maybe
possibilities like you have to get the
Rook to H4 and it came back it's gonna
take a while well I kind of seriously
has found some killer moves and killer
ideas realizing that the queen should be
x-rayed but man I did a thing as alert
yeah he's definitely King G7 and then
Mark h8 yeah she actually played well to
win that piece I mean well okay the guy
he hung the piece but but she took the
piece that was hanging right but she
played well to be in the position to
take that piece you know what I mean
right like of course like the piece was
hanging she took the hanging piece as
you're supposed to and she did that in
fact but it just it was difficult to
actually oh yeah oh that's gonna hurt
yeah okay yeah yikes yeah it's tough
we're about to see the
the drop the emotional drop right there
I feel like she's trying to take the
queen
probably will be possible oh yes you
realize
yeah that one hurts but all smiles she
knows she's got another chance you know
so she's got another chance and she
always says like not over it's not over
yet you know like you gotta have that
type of mindset funny move King E6
Knight takes A7 and then Knight A7 25
maze deflection deflect deflection
deflection yeah you also have Knight C7
Queen F6 watch him play Queen E5 here
can you fight immediately boom still in
the game yeah wait why is the chess.com
not making that satisfying clicking mate
sound
you won you wait what wait it didn't oh
and then the Queen's gone
Queen E8 good move it's made in a couple
of moves here just Knight can drop in to
C7 100 Rook F7 mate
beautiful yeah seven as well we have
seven
will he fight I feel like he's gonna
take the pawn
for some reason he doesn't have time
there it is hey
hey right hands up in the air there
is celebrating celebration I did a thing
mistakes half his head there mostly uh
wall okay but he wants still in it
it's a cool wall
fireworks fire in that corner up there
yeah
yeah I was gonna ask is that the famous
spider and no yes he's got it chilling
out yeah yes cool that's my buddy
well that buddy helped him secure
victory in his first game against fousey
I did a thing leads Bruce Lee one to
zero it was an excellent opening fousey
clearly prepared playing All the Right
Moves In the Karo Khan winning a piece
and then yes she blundered her Queen but
the preconditions of the turnaround were
laid a couple of moves prior to that
James she weakened her King a little bit
too much but great spirit if she plays
like that in game two she's got a shot
this was a topsy-turvy contest could
have gone either way absolutely like her
perspective I mean she was just like
yeah I mean you know very like not sure
like I like literally don't care type
attitude did you see from icaru like a
very strong play we just you just go
with it have fun play the game oh
emotions happen right they didn't let
her get it didn't let her you know
didn't get her down she was just kept
working and I tried to make the best of
it lost the game you know I gotta bounce
back and see what I can do with the
white pieces now so still chances but
okay you know I did a thing won the
first one suppose he's gonna have to try
to win second one so got the games
coming up right
and unlike the previous match the time
really was not a factor for either side
which is good to see they were playing
confidently but not fast to the point
where they're just making random moves
they were making a genuine effort to
find the best move
and we'll see what the second game holds
in store for us we are underway I think
fousey plays the London system but I'm
not totally sure she has played D4 yep
okay I remember that from the previous
five Champs don't ask me how I know can
we get a Jar Jar Binks come on come on
hit him with nice C3 just do it just do
it okay close you still got a chance for
all my uh Joe Bible London fans out
there and I see very nice either nicely
yeah I think some Levee videos were have
been consumed here on the partner the
player with the white pieces
some C4 Bishop D3 yeah we want RCA jar
jar being Sergio Baba London today but
London system very easy open and play
interesting we had the same exact
tension between the Bishops in the
previous game and funnily enough the
London and the Karo Khan are kind of
twinsies like you actually can have
positions that occur out of both
openings like the same position
you have seen an exchange Carol Khan
many times I actually learned this later
on it's like the same position exchange
Carol Khan as a um as a London system
exchange London there it is C5 and stuff
like that pretty cool Knight heads to
the center firstly can eliminate that
Knight but that grants black the bishop
pair
which is considered to be a long-term
strategic advantage and that is an
tactical Miss because the bishop is
undefended that's one two is that the
Bishops are in a standoff and three is
that the Knight can jump into F2
eliminating the pawn attacking the queen
forcing the king out and then he
recapture the bishop with an extra Pawn
does either the thing sense that
something exists in this position I
think he does he's taking his time here
bro this is a reverse line oh man this
is reverse Joe Baba though like this is
reverse this same trick reason how I
know I just remember looking at this you
know I have the course coming out for
accessible right so I was just looking
at this from the white side literally
everything was played from a job London
standpoint from the black side 94 trying
to play G5 H5 next with the bishop on F4
I was pretty sick out of two obviously
was the move there but man this is
pretty cool to see in reverse a London
against the London right really in a way
of course uh but night before was
stopped with upon on C3 here pretty nice
I don't think I did a thing knew that
but at the same time it's very cool 2C
from him right now Knight F2 is still on
the cards here is he going to find it
you didn't see it once will you see it
now Knight C32 as well
it's a pretty Advanced tactic though it
just kind of comes out of nowhere it's I
think he sees that the Bishops are in a
standoff but maybe he's only considering
Knight takes Knight which is you know a
likely move at a newer level but G5 he
is playing all of the job my guy
basically oh and foosleep looking at the
wrong thing right she noticed that pawn
on G5 and she's like get that pawn out
of the way Black's like sure I'll get
that pawn out of the way all right yeah
that's a tough one that's a tough one
well she was up a piece the first game
and lost down a piece the second will
she win let's look into her stream how
is she taking the loss of this dearly
departed relative on F4 right
um okay he's threatening this which I
can kill with this he's threatening this
which I can kill with this
um he's threatening nothing here he's
threatening nothing there he's not
nothing nothing Bam Bam Bam whoa
you know what me too me too
move I can make
is there something else I can challenge
well what if I just put my knife here
right what if I just did it
I like how the knights are like the
knights are pulsating yeah on the Square
on these lights right yeah very very
nice perspective
um from Frozen here this is a great I'm
gonna be winning the game she's having
fun bro five and then trying to win the
game too as well all right keep just
saying okay wait so but then he has this
and this is defending it and okay wait
oh
I wonder what's he gonna take oh my God
he castled the long way not what I
expected at all
what are we gonna do here oh good that's
not good at all I would take the Knight
on C6 or ruin it's great like strategy
ranks that's exactly what we needed
because what if we go boom but do not
Castle King said whatever you do do not
Castle King side here
because Rogue G8 and queen takes H4 is
mate whoa oh she castled King oh man
no way
and it's made into literally just
Checkmate Queen takes H4 because her
King side is ruined by the move she
takes F4 and that's what fusely failed
to appreciate that open G file never
castle and there's an open file directly
to your King James oh man he sees it he
saw it and I saw him at work like I saw
that his lips said his Checkmate now
I've ever seen
that was amazing I loved that okay let's
see what everyone's saying that was so
good
okay this is very meta I think I did the
thing is checking out our commentary
right now
so he's gonna see himself talking about
himself on our stream and ourselves
talking about him on his stream that was
so now I'm watching on YouTube
okay well we will have a chance to ask I
did a thing about that genius move he
wins the match convincingly winning both
games the first one back and forth the
second one that was just a blowout
fously giving away that Bishop opening
the G file and then castling the wrong
way all credit to I did a thing that was
pretty smooth very smooth here of course
he does have the experience more and was
playing and he got that lucky spider
which is really strange how lucky that
spider is but he also did have just a
very good game here very unlucky for
who's Lee here but hey is what it is the
chess is a very brutal game I did a
thing it's now at the top here of his
group at least so feeling good about
that match he is
indeed he is let's check out the group D
standings this puts I did a thing ahead
of the pack at Four Points he is perfect
fusely still scoreless but if she
continues working on her fundamentals
her openings are good I think she's got
the systems in place cutie Cinderella
and fusely will try to get on the board
and they've got plenty of opportunities
to do just that with Papa let sorry Papa
flat a lot of peas there a lot of
plosives piling on to pop a plat but
Papa Platt will try to play a little bit
more plus okay I don't know what I said
I think we need a break we need a break
and we will
um get the players in for an interview
we'll ask fusely about her opening
choices and her thoughts and of course
we will ask I did a thing about all of
his chicanery there with Rook G8 and
queen takes H4 great match we will get
the players ready and we will be back
with more pogchamps five action on the
other side of this short break
come on
let's go
[Music]
Rook takes Knight and now Queen F2 Queen
g2s just game over like yeah and oh and
he's Queen up two oh no oh no oh no
we have two logic misses it Queen F2
what a throw
King E8 and then Queen C8 and there's
actually a staircase Checkmate oh man
watch it through maybe seven is made
Seven they're three mates here for white
oh my gosh oh what a huge throw let's go
today we're gonna go down into the New
York City subway set up a table on the
subway platform and see if we get some
strangers waiting for their trains to
play chess with us
[Music]
all right I'm gonna see if I can get
anybody
[Music]
sounds like he knows what he's doing a
little bit
[Music]
don't worry I'm not that good yeah
you're just out here playing chess not
that good got the chess.com app
you ever play on your phone oh yeah he
said he barely played I'm a teacher what
do you teach chess I'm just kidding
self-defense how do you stay sane
take medication
what's like lesson 101 of self-defense
run what are you listening to right now
train
Sean Paul Ed Sheeran what is the meaning
of life it's funny because like what I'm
doing I feel like doesn't align with my
philosophy on what the meaning of life
is but it's like obviously spent as much
time with family as possible the best
person you can be get closer to God not
to be evil to each other
[Applause]
I'll see you in a self-defense class
enjoy Harry Styles
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's really pretty
[Music]
foreign
two one here we go
[Music]
and we are back here day five of
pogchamps five another match in the
books unfortunately it did not go
fousey's way but we very much enjoyed
watching the games firstly there are a
lot of cool moments I'd like to start by
asking you what it's like to play as a
pogchamps veteran this is your second
POG Champs appearance and we really
admired the openness and the passion
just the lightness with which you played
the games what is it like playing Pock
Champs a second time and how has your
overall approach to this tournament
changed
um well the first one was I did a lot
more training I had like you know I did
lessons with Hess and Hikaru and I was
studying I wasn't sleeping
um because like you know e-rob I knew
was one of my opponents and I like
really couldn't get I couldn't Lucy Rob
so I was like stressing about that this
one Ludwig begged me okay and then I
thought I wasn't gonna do it and then
yeah and then I crammed this morning all
I was doing was watching openings I was
two x times on Gotham chest you know how
to win with the London system I haven't
opened on my right monitor okay 2X times
um so I had it the plan was to just do
the London and then you know but I lose
it after once I've executed the start
the bishop hat you know you get the
bishop out this little hat and then
and I was I did a thing as a genius okay
he pinned my king and my queen on that
first game and then my my mental it
crumbled okay and then I was shaking
from the rest of the two games it was
not okay Fork
it's a fork everything that Chad was
like oh Ben it was going crazy it was
great content I'm sure you did it on
purpose no I'm kidding but it was a it
was called a fork there actually too as
well so you know because you studying
your chest good to see it you had a
great perspective every time in the game
as it was just like you know things
sometimes in chest just don't go your
way but your perspective was very very
positive and well how do you keep such a
positive attitude or at least uh it
looks to us as you're doing so how do
you do it
well I run a couple puzzles beforehand I
do a couple bullet chess games
um and you know my confidence shoots up
I well no that's actually a lie because
I lost all those
um I don't know I just don't have
expectations for myself and then I kind
of just just smile through the pain
that's the way you're supposed to do it
unfortunately I know some I know some
Grandmasters who could uh learn a thing
or two from that attitude one last
question for you uh fusely do you feel
like pocchamps lights up your love for
chess do you feel like you want to go
out there play more Blitz or do you feel
like you need a break after this
tournament and you need just a reset uh
from from chess how does this tournament
make you feel
oh gosh what a hard question uh how does
it make me feel it makes me feel I mean
like part of me wants to be good at this
game but also it's like it makes me
realize I can't just cram it's not like
one of those like stuff all the
information in your brain type of games
but it is fun like it's fun while I'm
playing it it's definitely like you know
but it gets stressful because I'm like
well if I go here he takes and I take
that he takes and I take that he takes
that and then I go do that with another
position and then then the timer starts
and then I'm like ah and then I Castle
and then wow that's what happened in the
second game so wow it's stressful but
yeah it's fun I would I would probably
do it again maybe yeah I do it again
but put me against ikuno is there a way
we'll see what we can do that's that's
music to our ears that though foosleep
we really appreciate you coming out for
an interview and uh the passion with
which you played the games were
fascinating sorry the match didn't go
your way but thanks again we'll let you
take your much deserved rest
oh question am I the favorite to win in
any of these matches
um I think the matches are so
unpredictable that we're trying to avoid
the use of the word favorite
and that's not just the politically
correct answer I think that's absolutely
the case more Levy videos more opening
cramming I think you've got a great shot
in your last match
thank you so much I will show up
tomorrow
let's go you got it thank you Bruce Lee
okay that was firstly see you later
great match and we will go on a break
but before we do we wanted to remind you
um of something important which is to
not miss your to cash in on chess.com
twitch drops or in two weeks of diamond
membership by watching two or more hours
of chess with participating streamers on
Twitch you must connect your Twitch and
chess.com accounts to claim the reward
drops will only be available for a
limited time so don't miss it use
x-clamp drops in chat to learn how
that's exclamation mark drops in chat
cash in on chess.com twitch drop so
you'll want to cash in on this I did a
thing interview that will be coming up
on the other side of this break we will
find out his thoughts the genius as
fously proclaimed him or we will enter
the genius's mind and get more pocchamps
action in just a couple of moments
thank you
[Music]
come on
thank you
[Music]
foreign
three two one
[Music]
welcome back ladies and gentlemen Tupac
jams five day five that is I did a thing
who has just defeated fousey
convincingly with a score of two nil two
really interesting tactical games and
the second one concludes in Checkmate I
did a thing thank you for joining the
studio we will interrogate you all about
these two games fusely called you a
genius on several occasions and I'd like
to start by asking this
gee there's so many night Forks so many
Concepts in the first game you gave up a
piece but then you came back with a
vengeance what would you say clicked
that helps you turn this match around
after that initial blunder
well I I after that I just kind of told
myself I'm like oh you need to focus a
bit don't don't leave anything hanging
move I think I moved too quickly a lot
of the times without actually thinking I
like to just react I'm just like you
know something happens and I'm like oh
and I just move a piece but I have to
slow myself down and actually think
about where I'm going
um but also I think the the pacing
changed a lot as soon as we got out of
the kind of like um the book opening for
uh what fusley was doing which I think
is the London
um it's it was
um did she do the London no mm-hmm
okay yeah but it's kind of like I'd seen
those openings before but then as soon
as it got out of that it kind of felt
like
uh her gameplay fell apart a bit so
firstly but it's like that was I don't
know if it was me playing better or it
was her playing worse you know
great congratulations man so about this
lucky spider I heard about the spider
you caught the spider and like this does
a very dangerous spider it's a good luck
charm how much luck has it brought you
so far here
quite a lot of luck well I won these two
games but I didn't win my my second game
with Papa Plateau when I brought it out
but um I actually lost the spider
um in the house somewhere uh which is
which is meant to be not possible
because I heard that if you put um
funnel webs in a glass jar they can't
climb the walls
um but it got out and I don't know
whether it's because the there was like
a lot of I rescued it from the pool so
the spider was wet so maybe because it
was wet it was able to kind of like
stick to the glass a bit better and make
its way out
but um yeah
there's a fun summer in the house now
on the topic of your various exploits
you have a really interesting YouTube
channel
um could you give us a little bit of
insight into what kinds of videos you
make and what are the inspiration type
Inspirations that you seek for all of
the amazing things that you turn into
videos
um yeah so my channel is kind of just
like I just make dumb things I guess is
the the way to describe it I kind of
like
whatever an idea comes into my head I'm
just like what's the best way to make
money out of this hurting myself you
know
um and that's kind of my channel it's
kind of it's kind of like a dumb a dumb
Myth Busters if MythBusters didn't
know how to make anything that's a good
summary of my channel
um but yeah I don't really know how I
get inspiration it's just um you just
look at stuff I guess
it's a bit of a can't really answer that
question
that's really fine it's really fun of
course guys make sure you're checking
that out
um what type of type of preparation that
does it take for you in fact what do you
actually do to get prepared for these to
get in the right mindset of course none
of these matches are really easy and you
do have to work and of course you
understand the pressure the time
pressure there it's a two game match
you're thinking about this what actually
type of training uh do you do for the
matches
I guess I was just playing a lot of
Chess
um just a lot of Chess
um with um foodsley specifically I saw
that she liked to play the London so I
watched a bunch of London uh videos
online
um my coach helped me out with that Joe
from chess.com
um and then also I think I watched one
of your videos Daniel about you playing
against the London or something like
that and it's like um yeah I think the
first six moves helped me and then the
rest of that I was like I'm not
following this or remembering this
I'm flattered thank you
but I was definitely playing too much
chess I don't know if this is a thing
you guys get when you play chess but I I
kind of got this thing I felt like was
chest brain where it's like I just
started to see chess moves everywhere
that didn't exist like I'm driving my
car and I need to overtake someone and
I'm like
and in in an L pattern to overtake him
like a horse I'm like no do not do that
while driving Alex like don't do it out
everywhere yeah yeah it's horrible
are you having chest hallucinations all
the time
I've lost games in my sleep and I wake
up mad and I'm like it's not even a real
game
but you know Diane does the same thing
I'm sure oh absolutely so many dreams in
which I beat Magnus Carlson in a match
and then wake up and face the sober
reality uh one more question
um you have a tough match tomorrow it's
a deciding match how excited are you for
that match and for the potential to
enter the Champions bracket
I'm actually very excited I think it's
fun I wasn't I wasn't expecting to do to
do well in this at all so I'm just happy
to really play Chess at this point
um and it's fun being on stream so I'm
I'm excited and hope that I win
and I've I've heard the kitty is
hardstock as she told me that in person
she was like I'm hard stuck at 800. so
that's a good sign for me I think
okay
well if you play the way you did today I
think you've got every shot you're
facing QT Cinderella tomorrow I did a
thing congratulations to scintillating
games today and uh best of luck in your
decisive match tomorrow we'll let you
rest up
thank you thank you thanks for having me
of course that was I did a thing who
crushes fusely with a score of two to
zero two very wholesome interviews but
the best part is that we have one more
match coming up in about 10 minutes from
now 7 P.M Eastern Sea Dog VA that's a
lot of vowels and consonants close
together who faces Frank James two
completely different matches like the
Arc of these two matches we just saw
could not have been more different and
now we've got a third match just amazing
how we're always all over the map when
it comes to the way that these matches
unfold
yeah more and of course when you have
players that have been more uh seasoned
I would say this is Sea Dog I've seen
him play a lot in fact actually in many
Paul Champs and also like uh having a a
favor to him or like yo he's good yo
he's gonna do this he's going to do that
so Sea Dog there but he is up against a
good Frank right now he's playing well
as well so we will see you know kind of
what happens here anything happens with
two matches on the line only two games
you lose one you're already Under
Pressure to lose the match so it is very
difficult it's a lot of pressure on
these guys and I mean the best a content
creator win here is always the thing
here all channels five with this match
coming up well cdog VA is leading his
group he's a seasoned uh player although
the one thing we should add is that he
is based in Japan and it is very early
in the morning for him and we know it is
a universally acknowledged truth that
chess players and mornings don't exactly
go great together but hey maybe he's a
morning person as we look at his resume
card right there voted the best
philanthropic stream uh
in 2023 based on the streamer Awards and
most important that final bullet point
over 500 games played experience equals
good performance in a high pressure
tournaments and he's been showing that
thus far in the POG champs as we look at
his stream and he's diligently putting
in some practice games getting those
losses out of the way now yeah you get a
monster system and you also get some
fuel to the fire you're like oh you know
what let me just pre-move everything I'm
about to lose this game can't wait to
play the next one so whoever is in the
way we'll get hit let's see is this
gonna be a stalemate nope oh my gosh
[Music]
Rook C4 then that would have been
stalemate but great to see Sea Dog
putting in those practice games and
taking the match seriously because his
opponent is no joke
he is playing against Franken Frank is
also 4-1 he is also rampaging through
the field he plays fast he gives himself
pep talks he is a very flamboyant player
and I think we're already seeing that
just from that small snippet of his
stream he is a YouTube chess sensation
with over 60 million views super
passionate about his Improvement and
obviously Frank is a chess YouTuber so
he blows everyone out of the water when
it comes to experience level
a thousand plus games he really serious
that's a lot of games you don't just do
that on the you know on the weekend
thing buddy that takes some time a
thousand games plus they're making the
content there and now he's gonna try to
make it work
today against a very seasoned and
Veteran Sea Dog also probably mad
because he's losing his bullet games
there so you know we'll see what happens
this is going to be more I'm very
excited to see this match this might be
more high level than the other matches
here but let me see you again you never
know it is uh it is a two game match and
really anything can happen lots of
surprises and you got to be in great
form
it's interesting also how players are
divided by puzzle Battlers and puzzle
rushers versus people who play Blitz in
order to prepare and we see the two
approaches the warring approaches there
with Frank choosing to do puzzles and
Sea Dog choosing to play and just get
the Jitters out of the way by playing
there's no right answer both approaches
are totally valid and both approaches
have allowed this incredibly strong
group to move forward you've got Jarvis
Franken Seadog closely packed together
with Sea Dog and Frank tide with Five
Points apiece so the stakes could not be
higher because if one of these players
blows out the other then well this is
the final match of this entire group so
I guess that they've secured
qualification but nonetheless it's the
battle of the best players in the group
and that is always one to watch James
absolutely sometimes you just never know
you you're rooting for one oh he's gonna
blow him out the water but then it's the
other way around or you'll be like oh
this guy's gonna do this but then they
do that you know so it's definitely
something to pay attention to with five
versus five in group a there they're
just going crazy and they're trying to
close it out and clean some spots here
with this final match is going to be
very exciting to us indeed it is and if
you are someone who uses a calendar who
likes to cancel meetings in preparation
for a day of POG Champs just wanted to
quickly remind you that there will be
matches tomorrow the entertainment does
not stop tonight tomorrow we will start
at 3 P.M Eastern Time noon Pacific with
virtual against daily dose of Internet
who is still trying to get on the board
at 4pm we will have foosli trying to
redeem herself from today's match
against Papa Platt I feel like I could
say that 15 times in a row pop clap clap
yeah it's the letters blur together so
finally we will have QT Cinderella the
match that uh I did a thing just
referenced his final match of uh the
initial bracket against the hard stock
cutesy Cinderella that'll be a close
match and finally we will in fact have
the star of stars xqc we'll take on
Jenny to round off the day at 6 PM
Eastern I know a lot of people really
looking forward to seeing xqc in POG
Champs after
the craziness that ensued from pogchamps
one which feels like it was a decade ago
it's crazy to think that that was only
what three years ago right I mean it's
crazy how big Polk Champs has became
here and like all the celebrities we've
been able to bring on and how big chess
is and how many people love the game
rather we're clapping patches let's get
some collabs to the chat patch yourself
on the back chat for watching and being
a part of this commentary and this uh
part of Paul Champs or Another Year guys
I just think it's so telling that we
almost talk about pocchamps as a normal
occurrence it is and I mean that in the
best possible way but to have this
assemblage of top streamers and content
creators and not just in one sub field
right not just Gamers who play one
particular thing but we've got people
from all over the map of the internet
you know different types of YouTubers
and people on Twitch and and different
types of content creators and all of
them are coming around and revealing in
many cases a long-standing interest in
chess it's not like they learned the
rules yesterday of course the levels
vary some of them are better some of
them are newer to chess but every single
one of them is into it nobody's there
because they were forced to be there and
I think that's a very valuable thing I
think it's it epitomizes just how much
chess has seeped into just our popular
culture
absolutely I mean chess even referenced
it in of course Sports as well outside
of Chess where they say like oh they're
playing chess out there what does that
say about us right that's just like when
you hear that you're like feels greater
when you see that movie they got the
king and queen switch then you're like
ah I might be 400 but I know that's
gonna put your king and your queen and
that is what makes chess so special
there because we're all a big family and
a nice Community here and Paul Champs
five the entertainment is through the
roof here and again I'm here with my
twin brother Donya I cannot be more
happy
I could not be more happy either I'm
having a great time and we are about a
minute away from the start of the final
match today so if you're just joining us
if you're heading home from work and are
catching the last match just reminding
you that each match consists of two
games and a Time control of 10 minutes
plus five seconds per move that's called
an increment which means five seconds
get added to your clock per move we want
to eliminate crazy time scramble give
the players just a little bit of time to
settle down and think about their moves
in the event of a 1-1 tie which we had
in our first match of the day the tie is
broken with a faster time control game
three minutes with a five second
increment and you keep playing if you
keep drawing games until a winner is
declared okay seat belts fast and James
last match of the day
really unpredictable I have no idea what
we're going to see from these two
leaders of the group probably would be
fitting to get a tiebreaker but I don't
know this is going to be amazing yeah
it's very it's really about you know
who's in great form a lot of jitters
there sometimes you see the biggest
matchups of the ones that are very close
sometimes become blowouts or like just
2-0 one guy just sharp the other guy
trying to rebound from the loss they
might have you know uh just just got
there trying to get over that loss
trying to like get your mind right
perspective lots to it so it's exciting
the message is going to start very soon
Sea Dog versus Frank chat put it in the
chat your prediction Sea Dog or Frank
who wins the match who wins the match
I feel like
I don't know it's Sea Dog is much higher
rated but oh no no Frank okay Frank is I
was seeing 200 no he's 875 so Frank is a
little bit lower rated in fact Sea Dog
over a thousand but
again just from today we see that
ratings are completely meaningless you
can take these numbers and throw them
into the trash can it's the least
important factor and they're so volatile
anyway and we're underway we're underway
here in the last match of fifth day of
POC Champs what will we see another
Scotch are we Lopez a ponciani something
Frank is definitely uh in the chat they
all Frank Frank Frank there's some Sea
Dogs in there with a lot of
them and the four nights it appears
night coming out to C3 this is one of
the oldest openings in existence this is
what people used to play you know back
in the days when they would dump their
uh refuse in the streets
so this opening has existed for many
many hundreds of years it's completely
symmetrical
completely symmetrical here lots of
things can happen I think 95 is a move
here and I remember some of the theory
from here from the black side I never
played it from white but I do know like
Knight D5 I think it's a move or
something strange remember what that is
A3 very natural move taste takes
they say thanks
yeah this is a this is a very tame
opening so so hard to make any hard and
fast conclusions now typically the E4
Pawn is left hanging uh in these types
of openings and taking it is very
dangerous because the Knight gets
vulnerable you could end up losing the
E5 pawn and Frank kind of taking up the
gauntlet but gotta make an interruption
here James we have a very positive piece
of good news that we have gotten a word
that we will in fact get one more match
today uh after this one is concluded and
it will in fact feature xqc against
squeak so xct is going live right now
and he will in fact be playing his match
today to round off the day so we've got
more POG Champs action even more than we
expected which is always a great thing
James xqc will play in just an hour or
so wow so y'all see that there it is the
chat going crazy
let's go ah yeah there it is all the
energy
from the chat there they are they woke
up when they heard xqc's coming
incredible X you see pretty small
streamer though I'm surprised the people
in the chat even know who that is he's
not really popular I was giving him some
advice the other day on really how to
get more twitch followers and how to you
know how to broadcast himself in front
of Greater number of people because he's
not really good at that exactly yeah of
course yeah he's you know this is not
his day job understandable
okay
960 Queen you gotta move it he's gonna
move it do you have to move the queen
and it does appear that Queen Z5 is a
good concept but it doesn't quite work
in this position because you can't take
on E5 you have to drop your queen back
and black is just a healthy pot up
which he I think he realizes too as well
you just move the queen and we uh maybe
played D6 something's very solid here
very solid but Sea Dog already slightly
in some trouble here's down that pawn I
grabbed the pawn and go I'll grab and go
here Queen has to move out of the way
where is he going to put it
where is he going to put it is the
question you just go all the way back to
D1
probably all the way back to D1 the what
you don't want to do is go D3 well if
only we could have a little bit more
input as to more opinion as to where the
queen should go and we actually do we
have a very special guest joining us in
the studio streamer gamer extraordinaire
Sonic Fox is joining us
welcome Sonic box in honor and a
pleasure to have you in the studio
from the VR world with a bunch of
wonderful VR chest friends here they're
all here to support and you know
watch some chess from the greats you
know
wow beautiful green onion right here
against this cat good time
wow I mesmerized by that background yeah
this is sweet bro I'm just looking at
the background I have fire oh you like
it yeah yeah this is why I go to like
learn chess and get good at people so
I'm trying to Pioneer VR chest so y'all
see that wow VR chest that's where
we going next yes getting that over the
board feeling just like like because you
know typically chess
um is played online especially like you
know across the world but being able to
get that over the board feeling in
person in VR I just think it's nothing
like it
wow
but I wanted to I wanted to tackle the
big question though which is that you
are not playing in POG Champs because
you are too strong for it you're an 1800
rated player
um and let me be totally clear you would
rip this field apart this would not have
been close for the other players how
does it feel to be too literally too
cool for school
it's a little it's a little Bittersweet
you know sometimes like I I I've seen
that I'm going damn I really wanted to
go against like Frank I want to go get
six you see like this could be really
fun but at the same time getting the
chance to like even commentate with you
guys I think it's pretty cool
um
I I've been in a little bit of a
plateauing a bit I I was 1800 and now
I'm down to 1700 like I'm sure you guys
know when you have those games you just
go down 100 points yeah that's me right
now and I kept to climb back up so Dan
yeah I really need you to coach me
I gave you my word we will definitely be
doing some sessions and um maybe for
pogchamp six they will they will do
Sandy yeah it's definitely gonna happen
I think there's no doubt about that have
you been following uh the podcast how
closely have you been watching the games
and uh just sort of you know marveling
in all the blunders and mistakes
um if I'm being honest uh I haven't been
able to because I've been you know doing
my own personal fighting game stuff
um going out and participating in a
bunch of events but
um and even now like this week I'm not
sure if there's like a like a Super Bowl
equivalent for like chess but like
there's a Super Bowl equivalent for like
fighting games this weekend so that's
like which is called Evo and that's
where like my entire Focus has been so
unfortunately I haven't been able to
watch too much but
today I can so yeah hey good luck on Evo
too as well I'll be watching a little
bit on the Stream So chat chat's
familiar as well they're like yeah let's
go Evo
oh my gosh are you seeing what I'm
saying Sonic was G6 just played in this
game
are we oh it's not just a free piece oh
you don't have to see that with the VR
on to know that one and like can you can
you even stop meat here because you play
G6 and then
yeah it's just over okay yeah you have
the dark squares on the king side
Bishop takes F6 it's coming oh
oh my gosh she didn't take it but
is is he just sort of delaying the
pleasure you know just saying your
knight isn't going anywhere yeah
you're saying my knight oh my knight
you can see it in his face he was
mouthing it oh my knight oh my God but
how do you defend Checkmate if you take
with the bishop and then you know you
place a knight with it you know
that's some nasty stuff there nasty yeah
King G7 also there's Bishop H6 but let's
see it first off Frank has to find this
move because if he gives up the Knight
again I think White's gonna take it
let's see what what he's thinking oh
whatever he's thinking out well danger
levels
show your Knights under attack not
assessing the danger for sure
can't save McDonald night Midnight's
completely wrong
what's going on what's going on right
now
that's the first bottle of water
bottle of water it's
okay
it takes
oh you're kidding me you're absolutely
kidding me my nice guy do you think
black here knows how to stop the meat my
light is
Daniel
okay I think so I think Queen well I was
trying to figure out if after Queen D6
Knight G5 there is a defense but I think
there is you can play H5 so I don't see
the force made just yet if he plays
Community second he just did he's still
in the game
this is where Knight G5 was uh was a
very annoying move but he has H5
H5 only movie has to find that
hmm why not why not uh pin oh sorry why
not Fork the queen in the
and The Rook here
Sonic Fox but you are looking right you
know we gotta get we gotta get that ELO
back up we working on yeah you know I'm
a little bad so you know to the viewers
like 1800 a lot of chat has not even
reached that ever so Sonic Fox very nice
stuff as well look nice ideas what is
going on bro he just took on F3 bro this
is very strange now yeah give me an
Advil here
well I don't think you can play Queen
there right not yet because the queen
can just take the bishop
if you could deflect the queen I think
Bishop takes D5 is a very Nifty move
here luring the queen onto D5 only the
queen could move like yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
then Queen H6 wins the game but that's a
that's a very Advanced idea Sonic do you
do like Puzzles regularly what what
would you say is your go-to method of
training throughout your life
uh just do it
maybe not again I do play puzzles but uh
my main um way of training honestly is
by doing a lot of studying whether it's
just watching players like yourselves
play or
um just like looking up the most recent
um video that you know Levy uh captured
on
uh whether it was online in chess or at
a random Mouse tournament because
there's always tournaments going on
everywhere but
um
yeah that's pretty much the only way I
train
by entering the dungeon that's the way
to do it Queen takes place I think
Bishop takes C5 but he found the move
that was incredible
mate oh yeah Unstoppable me that's GG
see dog
incredible he found Bishop takes D5 that
was a double exclamed move that was the
first brilliant move of this day maybe
one of the first ones in box jams five
first Brilliance of fog Champs that
wasn't E4
yeah E4 Knight F3 exactly
dog with a win here very nice Bishop 55
Queen H6 no way to stop mate it can even
be pre-moved G7 made very nice from Sea
Dog here
[Music]
not bad yeah
black is coming to terms with the fact
that there isn't even a single way to
Stave this off by a move
for the viewers at home especially since
you you both have competed all right wow
you know you're just since we're winning
boys why don't we celebrate with the
glasses press the design button like how
does that start early it's nine o'clock
somewhere in the world am I right I
think my my biggest thought is
oftentimes when you're sitting there and
not resigning it's not so much that
you're looking for a save you're cycling
through what you might have done wrong
and you're oh it's degenerative
let's do it experiencing the pain of the
good position that you had and how it's
evaporated so a lot of times you see
players like grabbing their head and you
know doing all these things
the previous moves of the game Sorry I'm
trying to focus well sea dog is talking
and just coming to terms with with what
they've done wrong but Canty I think
you'll Echo that this is one of the most
painful Sensations it's like before
you've resigned but when you know that
you've already lost and Frank he knows
he's lost because he is down the score
of one to zero he's tough Frank's down
how Sea Dog feels really good he got the
win there and it feels good to get that
win I just want to do it again and again
because you got to keep working you have
to go into the same next game with you
know the mindset I got my latest game
like you say exactly I gotta do it just
do it sorry let's get a Nike sponsorship
somewhere around here please thank you
appreciate it but you just gotta do it
there right so and that's uh exactly
what Sea Dog is gonna have to do and
Frank because it's gonna be a very nice
match up here especially Frank having
white in this next game we'll see what
happens Frank's just gotta do it
um and as a fellow competitor too at
least for fighting games there's
definitely such a certain situations
that like we also have similar chess
terms called like Checkmate scenarios
and things like that too so having that
like feeling of like damn I was doing so
well what could have possibly went wrong
here and then just
everything in your hands just completely
crumbles into just completely lost
position I I can I can definitely feel
that like
that despair you know yeah yeah
definitely yeah you always make a
comment like yeah you know we just I
could flip the board or I could just
like literally get up flip the entire
assessment you know what I mean right
but we you know then you're going to be
invited to anymore but that's always a
thought that crosses your brain and then
you just come to senses and say I'm not
gonna do that today let me just resign
and then you figure out I've never seen
people swimming at people that fight
again events so nearest chess boxing
right right well we're we're waiting for
the next game to begin and Frank was
doing well that moved G6 that just it
was a blunder which came out of nowhere
uh I'll guess I'll take this opportunity
to Sonic by asking you how you got into
gaming uh in the first place what was
your inspiration and do you feel like
like when you're watching Pock jams or
you're playing chess that you're
actively noticing the the parallels
between the games that you play best and
uh of course which is chess and and
chess
yeah I I figured the conversation was
not not talking about fighting games
um so I I was in um VR actually because
I I played this game religiously I was
at VR one day and a friend by the name
Finn um fennec um we were just hanging
out and then I saw a test board and I
remember as a child in middle school I
used to play chess a lot that seriously
just casual so you know I'd Blended my
pieces left and right but I had so much
fun and so my friend we were in a random
world we just had a chessboard and he
was like hey let's play a game and I
played it and I'm I'm grateful that I
did because my passion for chess since
then the guy completely reignited I was
like wait I love this game actually why
don't I stop playing it and with the
mindset that I have now especially with
how far I've gotten alongside fighting
games and how I use it to learn
um I used a lot of that knowledge to
learn chess a lot better and ever since
then I've been like trying to study some
more courses got a lot of courses from
Levi's following you Daniel for about 15
months now I'm not sure if you've
noticed but
um I just been studying quietly and um
in a matter of about two years
um I went from like 600 to 1800 now I'm
at 1700 but I still remember like being
at 600 and just going like
how do you even get good at this game
how do you even get to 700 I don't
understand it's impossible this game is
not for me but I promise you if you have
to work ethic and you just keep studying
and have friends that want to keep
playing with you like like even a friend
right here this little beautiful cat
right here that's playing chess on the
table has helped me so much of getting
better at chess so
that's right so it takes work whoa
speaking of work here this position is
about to get worked right now boy this
is crazy D5 is the best move in this
position from the black side I'm sure
Daniel knows as well Knight C6 already
in trouble Sea Dog is if he's able to
find Pawn takes in D4 strike the center
very early get ourselves a very nice
Vienna from Hawaii
yeah I think Savannah's going crazy
right now
Vienna definitely got very popular in in
recent years I know Levy's recommended
it it's a very practical opening and if
you misplay it you have the potential to
be losing within a couple of moves are
you an E4 player or a D4 player Sonic
like by by Nature I'm pretty Dynamic you
know I'm gonna create like I watched the
show Queens again but you know once and
as a result I could only play Queens
okay so I I like to play it more Dynamic
I'm a D4 player
very mature I feel like most players
when they begin are E4 players and then
over the course of time they realize
that D4 is actually a very good move and
they should have given it more credit to
begin with
so definitely a solid choice but a very
solid choice for Frank who is just
starting to push black off the board in
the early golf game
definitely pushing them push him those
pawns are very very strong in the center
there Knight has to go back to G8
literally you have to go backwards he
plays now but the follow-up is very
important here you guys see Frank is
height boy frankly I got him he's moving
back let me sip my water real quick put
it down now time to work and let's see
Tommy I grabbed a Master Level when she
was not in this position right here be
honest
um it's losing I think it's I wouldn't
resign but I would say that at a gym
level in an OTB game this is lost
objectively lost it's lost it's
objectively we're even D5 here I think I
would already come to terms with having
lost that's how narrow the margins are
as we're listening to Frank he's going
crazy
I love his energy bro
yeah that just goes right another free
peace development right there and
doesn't really solve the problem with
them
completely shut down by white and I
wanna we wanna get there okay if I go
here he can't take because porn is
winter King all right okay
well no come on baby
he goes there right we pin pull into the
king okay pin my own Pawn to the king
that's Luke that's new Danny I'm with
him though I'm with him I'm with him
I like Queen's paying attention
I go there oh we want to Castle up we
want to Castle up Bishop G4 is a good
move though I think Frank was too
focused on tucking his King away now
there's Knight 64. and black is starting
to get this piece is out to pretty
active squares it's not lost anymore
okay boom Oh there's a G4 yeah see dogs
on it I think C dot well okay he did it
wasn't as accurate but let's see how
they open it here but the opening is not
everything
yeah
there's some counter play happening okay
64. not even looking at it we go there
we
go oh my goodness here it comes
right right okay there's that pawn and
that's a center Pawn that's not just any
pawn okay now
but
like Queen G2 is very like you know uh
attacking like you hit G7 and then you
make and go Bishop E1 very strange move
but open up the D file and stuff like
that or even Bishop E3 trying to help
you take on C3 so D5 opens up and just
like wild chess here that's what this is
you might have to take it into that
territory
yeah I mean possible there like a
thousand so you know it's just gonna be
fireworks no matter how you look at it
that's exactly right
it's about to be very very uh sharp
fireworks Queen D3 hits both night you
move the Knight we can take on D5 get
the pawn back
a lot of stuff hanging here that pawn
was sort of eating from The Forbidden
tree a little bit no but your king side
is it okay
to hear those if the Knight if the
Knight Retreats then the queen gets the
card that um that pawn again so it's not
a free Pawn yet oh no it is
I would take it with the Knight I
wouldn't take it with a queen because
any situation where you've got the
initiative you don't want to trade
Queens maybe he'll be tempted by Queen
B5
but super important for Frank just to
see that that pawn is attacked more
times than it's defended oh wrong wrong
wrong
yeah
he wants to play E6 hopefully he played
rookie one two
now
definitely can take that
a D4 or something like that
stopping D4 wow yeah I mean I still like
I mean why has a great attack potential
that's what you'll say yeah
I was gonna say because if he takes if
he takes the uh Bishop of this Knight
and then he takes back with the bishop
he could potentially start considering
you know pushing that pawn and trying to
win that Free Pawn over there
um and potentially taking the Rook too
you think CDOT sees that are pushing on
E6 and Bishop takes G7 something like
that very possible Queen B5 potential
and White's position lots of the black
has to get the king side out because as
long as the king
remains in the center White's always
just basically whatever white does is
going to be dangerous for black so Sea
Dog just has to sense that you can't
play without your whole King side like
this
yeah
it's got this butter dancing in the
background watching the stream too
bad in here
it's having a good time
whoa Ivan over there look at that just
getting it beautiful
I'm not trying to start getting excited
because if I get a little excited I
might start doing you know backflips on
stream you know so I don't wanna oh my
gosh did you just do that in real life
or like how to do that oh yeah I totally
did how does that even work
oh yeah I totally did
whoa I didn't even hear like that you
didn't even hear the feet or nothing
like the
you know
I needed myself that's why
oh wow this man is legendary wow that
was that was crazy but over there
finally as the game as as the game
starts to enter the middle game Sonic we
uh will excuse you to watch the games in
peace
um we really really appreciate you for
coming on you're a legend and uh you are
literally too strong for pogchan so we
congratulate you for that and we hope to
have you on uh for more exciting
commentary and entertainment enjoy the
games and uh thanks a bunch for coming
on no worries thanks for having me a
lesson soon you'll cross two thousand
yes please do please do all right come
on I'll catch you all around catch you
later
all right that was Sonic Fox gamer chess
player extraordinaire
and in the meantime the position has
just sort of stabilized
just like that dancing butter in the
background oh man it's so smooth bro he
was like yeah it's so smooth and I'm
like oh Don you got him again smooth
butter like
oh great that's Donya dancing the
picture of the picture of smooth oh yeah
we did what was we dancing at in Oslo
with Tanya in them and doing that Tick
Tock dance
you Donya David Howell doing it I
remember that evening yeah that was fun
that was very fun it's about the Oslo
pursue check
ing out the way
and F4 Maybe
either four maybe six I mean there's
many ways to play it feels like Frank
has lost his initiative I mean that much
I think is clear let's see how Sea Dog
is handling this difficult opening he's
been kind of in the woods for a long
time what's he thinking about here
subscribe for me
[Music]
at least it looks great for me
I take
you may just take
yeah I'm gonna defend this
no shame in defending Connor
okay nice mindset there
[Music]
I think the Pawn's still free for me I
just want to make sure that
I get rid of every threat before I do it
because I'm very meditative stream right
right I think I'm chilling I just gotta
up
I don't know
that was like a slightly unexpected turn
forget about this it was very calm and
then he just like yeah you know what I'm
saying that's what we got to do
he just you know calling it like it is
and he's taking the pawning five and
making progress it feels like Frank has
sort of been spinning his wheels not
sensing the moment when he had to strike
in the center now he's two pawns down
and black has managed to get a good
position without developing the king's
Knight which is pretty impressive that
is pretty impressive in fact you do need
to follow development obviously and but
every chess game is usually a little
different here so we we didn't have to
move the king tonight at least not yet
but we are going to have to do that to
get the rest of our pieces out I mean
unless he hangs his Queen here which
doesn't do it
is oh my goodness of course your faults
give me something yeah
I want to hear Frank's reaction when he
gives up restaurants what is he thinking
right now he's gonna go there he takes
that oh take yes and then you lose their
own okay okay I win material out of this
position could go there for that's in
two pieces not too scared because I'll
just win I'll just win the queen and
then
mate so this is a nice Queen I like it
he doesn't realize that black can take
the rookie
tasty pin right there wow she's about to
be in for a cold shower threatening that
Queen and if he doesn't okay he takes oh
oh that's nice oh that's nice right
there oh that's foul that is
still my Beating Heart oh goodness me
oh that's disgusting that's disgusting
he's wondering all the rest of his
pieces did I not think that through okay
okay that was that we always ask
ourselves
trade Queens for now okay boom we'll go
there next
bishop and there's a background that's a
great position to be in when it rains it
pours that's just the golden iron rule
of pogshams when you blunder one piece
you blunder six
yeah and that's tough I mean once you
it's hard to stabilize once you get hit
like that of course like even in like
boxing too with the chest boxing thing
you get hit you get days your knees
start to buckle you have to pounce on
that if you are the attacker here and I
hope for the best now as the defender
you do need to stabilize or at least try
to or else it can spiral out of control
as we see it not only in this match but
the mini Park Champs games in games
period but I can see dogs just like huh
something's not right here all right
takes F3 finds it hitting the Rook now
too
every one of his last four moves five
moves potentially six moves if he takes
on H2 has been a capture and white has
only made captures on two of those moves
which is it's never a good thing when
you capture orders of magnitude less
pieces than your opponent I think the
only thing that could go wrong for black
is other than stalemate is a back range
Checkmate so I would consider eventually
eventually developing the site from G8
at some point in the not so distant
future maybe after white plays Rook A3
and preferably before white plays rookie
8 made
yeah that's funny if that hurts I mean
that's proof man your heart drops
immediately when you when you get hit
like that you're like oh it's mate like
what am I doing and it hurts right and
then you're like just all these emotions
happen and then they're celebrating on
their end because they just hit you with
the little the little uh duopty there
got you with the okie doke back rank not
looking for your checks captures the
threats it's black to move where is he
gonna go nice on time here for Sea Dog
does need to develop the rest of his
pieces and try to convert
and you don't have to take on H2 I think
there's a lot of diminishing returns
when it comes to material in the sense
that when you have an initial amount of
extra material every subsequent Pawn
starts mattering a lot less like you're
up upon a second Pawn is huge because
there's a big difference between being
up one pawn and two pawns if you're up a
rook then another Rook is worth a lot
less in most cases than that second Pawn
because you're already completely
winning you already have an overwhelming
amount of material and I really like
that move 95 cover the e-file support it
with F6 bring your other pieces out
you'll take this Pawn if there's a good
chance to do that but your top priority
is just to ensure the safety of your own
King the sonics fox in the chat did you
enjoy the VR commentary absolutely
thanks for being there that was very
that was an experience pretty nice to
see it should have more of it and we
have Rook E3 on the board if he moves
the Knight well I guess you don't have
any wrong squares like nice E6 still
will block the mate Knight D7 you're not
going to F3 or G4 there's no reason to
I'm gonna close my eyes because I've
seen too much in POG Champs okay there
we go I'm gonna open them again
breathe we're good
we're good nothing crazy
there's just no way that white breaks
through this barrier if you had an F
Pawn you'd play F4 if you had a d-pawn
you'd play D4 but
white is running dry neither of those so
you can try King C1 and hit the Rogue
but I mean it's a futile effort as work
has to move we develop our pieces
working Bishop here versus the rest of
black pieces is not going to cut it
well Sea Dog takes a drink of his cold
brew or IPA or mountains
yeah look at him look at the little
sweat yeah
that yeah smell it swirl it look at it
reading a book bro he Flex it all like
look at him he's literally reading
during this game he is so bored with
this position that he he doesn't even
care he can play with one eye one hand
one the other hand on the glass of wine
he's holding
Frank's not just gonna take that though
I want to see how Frank is approaching
the Herculean task of slaying the Medusa
that's in front of him I don't know if
you can do that too like read it I mean
you could like there's nothing against
as long as there's nothing in chest
terms fiction book or something
what was I what was going through my
brain oh he's still reliving the pain of
these blunders I why didn't play that
move
something nice oh that thing I was
cooking oh goodness I would have thrown
whatever I was cooking in the bin okay
we'll just go there oh I mean goodness
uh it's a trade it's a trade at least
I'll take a trade I will take a trade
um yeah
I honestly don't know how things could
be worse right here
yeah this is it all started with G6 in
the previous game because he was playing
fantastic before that if you remember he
won a pawn in the first game it was all
going great then that inexplicable move
G6 and I feel like you never fully
recovered himself mentally
yeah especially uh with a fast game too
as well trying to look at him reading a
book like yo chat yeah reading on on
page uh 700 here oh no let me write this
down oh he moved he's like doing so many
things drinking the wine here Sea Dog is
feeling really good
and BC he wants to keep that Knight on
E5 for the rest of his life just tucking
his King away in the corner there's so
oh and there's a ladder made on D1 which
is understandable I think Frank just
wants no more to have to do with this
position he wants out of here he's
saying enough is enough oh and he just
lost it mate
he's too busy reading oh what does he
write he's actually writing something
down I'm curious is he writing him moves
I don't think he's random but maybe he
is writing the moves down at the game
but he's writing something
we'll have to ask him yeah where was I
made on G1 made on H1 he's flexing sorry
Frank
let me finish my coloring book okay he
is oh it is
coloring on usual Savage
good game now I can get back to my
coloring book and what matters most oh
my goodness he did him like wow raise
the glass to that ladder mate daily dose
of Savage
Oh my God you're not working yeah let me
just do some colors happy chat
look how good my coloring is
let's see how good is your color
look at that at the same time you're not
even doing chest moving the queen on
this one on his Bob Ross and over here
going crazy I mean this piece yes the
book my favorite chest uh you call it
the buttons wait did he draw that or is
he trying to call it very introspective
what the that looks like I'm 12 and
this is deep look at this we're all just
poems aren't we
wow well Sea Dog has the time he has the
skill and he's got the win over Frank a
score of two nil first game it was a lot
more competitive in the second game the
wheels really came off Frank he's very
passionate he has some good ideas but he
just couldn't keep it together couldn't
avoid the blunders and ultimately James
pogsham's matches are decided by one
move letters that's just what decides
the majority of these games absolutely I
mean as you see every I mean especially
in the game with that fienna game it was
already as you mentioned over at higher
levels that game was over in that Vienna
but it wasn't able to close out he
wasn't able to be accurate enough and
that just caused him to make some
blunders obviously blunders happen and
whoever's not me whoever it capitalizes
on that last blunder is the one who like
wins right Paul Champs five that one was
crazy Sea Dog wins 2-0 there taking down
Frank and crushing his map
crushing is right that puts him on top
with eight points Frank he is still in
great shape he will make his way to the
Champions bracket because the top two
spots Prevail so his previous victories
um guarantee him the spot despite the
loss today he was upset at the way the
games had gone but it doesn't impact his
place in the Winner's bracket and
fortunate for Jarvis a good result for
him and sukuno better luck next time
there will always be another POG Champs
but all kudos to Sea Dog that was an
impressive performance all around he had
the wine he had the coloring book he had
the skill and he punished all of Frank's
blunders and once again that is what
decides these matches we will have the
players here for an interview and we'll
have xqc with more poccham's 5 action in
just a couple of moments
okay
foreign
[Music]
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on look at this
the chess.com Community streamer program
is growing every day
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
trust.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
what is the banished Gambit game one or
game two game one game one no please
don't it's too soon Hikaru we didn't
even reach a climax yes yes yes
exactly what we practice for
this is the best player in his group so
I I thought I thought he played um
don't go king of five stalemate
oh two seconds on the clock
yeah baby there it is big win big points
oh my God Checkmate checkmate
are you yelling it's like you did
good move by him so you need to keep the
Rook on the a file to so you don't drop
your passport
oh god there goes the other Rook yeah I
I were gonna be able to capture it and
this will be a four straw
and now no mouse slip by Ruby it's just
Queen V8 instead of Queen B7 and um and
that's game over oh my gosh he might
have this is crazy he stopped at B oh
he's going the other way oh no he missed
it very nice wow
so
clean wow
amazing let's do this let's do the
respectful thing
I don't even know well it doesn't matter
because the ground you resigns yes
yes we're in it
[Music]
back we are at pogchamp's five day five
and another match in the books
unfortunately that match did not go your
way Frank but we appreciate you joining
us for an interview and we want to hear
your thoughts things seem to be going
well until you played that pawn move G6
in the first game do you feel like that
was the turning point of the match
um well probably because I yeah that was
probably the turning point because
I I don't really know I I thought that
was just a normal move in my eyes so
must have been the turning point in the
game
uh if if it did blunder something
I just thought it was a normal move
yeah it did it did uh hang the piece the
air the F6 Knight which I think we saw
you laughing at two like oh my knight oh
man my night and then you made another
move there and he asks you almost out of
the woods there but then you had a very
nice second game especially out of the
opening there looks like white of course
is very natural to be very uh much
stronger with white than you are with
the black pieces there get a very nice
Vienna out of the opening we were able
to take on E5 played D4 and you got the
center you got a big Center here great
preparation or was that preparation in
today's match I'm playing the Vienna
yeah I was I was up all night uh just
practicing the Vienna I actually uh
didn't sleep for a whole night not
because I was staying up all night
practicing near the end I was obviously
doing other things but I did practice a
Vienna in that time as well so because I
was like oh I know only two moves of the
piano I gotta learn more so I did learn
the Vienna yes
well that opening was a dream scenario
for you unfortunately it was complicated
it was hard to convert but I wanted to
ask you about uh your YouTube channel
and your chess exploits I think people
really really appreciate the energy and
the passion that you bring could you
give us a window into what your channel
is all about and what about Chess makes
you the most passionate and keeps
driving you forward on your journey to
Improvement Frank
um well originally I just wanted an easy
game to record that I could just put on
Tick Tock and so chess is really easy to
record and so then I started doing that
and I just thought it'd be like another
game that I could play but then I
started like doing quite well for views
and then I actually did start to enjoy
the game and then people kind of liked
well do do you kind of like what I was
doing and so then I've just kind of
played the game and just kept to what
I'm doing and I did I do really like the
games it's a really really fun game to
play
Frank who do you want to face in the
championship bracket what do you want to
face
um
um oh I'll take anyone on I'll take
anyone else
I'm gonna get back and I'll take anyone
on
I like that that's exactly the kind of
spirit that we're looking for here in
pogtense well we congratulate Frank on
making it to the Champions bracket today
didn't go your way but you maybe just
maybe we'll have your chance at revenge
on that note we will let you take your
welderserve rest we know it's late where
you are so Frank thank you for joining
us and uh best of luck in the Champions
bracket
thank you very much
all right well that was Frank he loses
O2 but the biggest consolation is that
he will not have to play the consolation
bracket he won his previous two matches
and so he guarantees himself a ticket to
the Champions bracket but Seadog was
honestly Unstoppable other than his
opening in the second game James
he was very smooth
yeah very smooth in fact he was uh he
got all those pieces too as well Sea Dog
kept his composure there then I mean
let's talk about Confidence from the
first game he was drinking wine he and
his coloring book so when he's in the
zone here you're gonna have to watch out
especially if seed dog start breaking
out the coloring book what they say when
Gary put the watch on you knew it was
over when the Sea Dog we get the color
bring book out you know it's gonna be a
bad day right so you got to be uh be
aware of that so good luck to him of
course in the next round
for sure and we will have his opponent
cdog VA in the studio for an interview
we will go set him up and then of course
we'll have the final match of the day
with xqc so don't go anywhere we'll have
more POG Champs action for you and an
interview with Sea Dog in just a couple
of short moments
foreign
[Music]
and we're back with Sea Dog VA the
winner of group a who ran through yet
another match to punch his ticket into
the Champions bracket a 2-0 victory over
Frank in very convincing fashion CDA
congratulations on two great games first
and foremost just your overall thoughts
on how the match went you seemed super
comfortable you were sipping on wine do
you feel like that was a part of your
success just your chill approach to the
match I I think you have to be in the
right mindset and that allowed me to
relax uh and get in the mindset where I
could just kind of not worry about it
don't doubt myself you know I felt like
sometimes when I doubt myself too much
in these games it comes back to bite me
you know so I think uh the wine was a
key aspect of making sure that I could
let loose a little bit I think there's
nothing wrong with that I'd love to see
a GM match where they open a Bud Light
or something I don't know
I'm sure you were you were in the
element you felt good and a lot of times
some GMS say actually when you feel good
you play good right so he was actually
had the wine flowing man brought out the
coloring book showing the chat there it
was really nice to see that of course
and you were winning and to have the guy
confidence to be like oh yeah when he
moved let me make a move and win now and
like finish this game with the coloring
book was nice to see there how long ago
on this coloring book
uh well I actually just got it so I was
really excited to crack that one out on
stream uh and I felt like today was the
right moment I wanted to say it for a
special occasion and I think the win was
that occasion uh the guaranteed win as
well with a brilliant move by the way I
know I'm not saying that that's
chest.com's words
um but I felt like that was a great move
as well
it was and we were commentating and at
that moment I mentioned that there is
This brilliant move it deflects the
queen to make the mating mechanism
possible but I called it a super
Advanced move and at first I thought I
accidentally made it on the board that
we were analyzing on but then I realized
you actually had played it and you
played it quickly too did that idea
occur to you immediately to deflect the
queen
uh I'd love to claim that it did I think
it took a a few seconds to figure it out
and decide that this was going to be a
good move I actually I knew I had that
many seconds left that square yeah
so I was pretty confident that I should
get that Queen to move I'm just offering
whatever it took just take everything uh
because we have made him one after that
I saw you doing where we watch you do
some bullet chess as a little bit of
preparation there before it matches
there you saw you was like you lost one
I'm like I'm sure someone on a heap like
hate losing maybe put it into the next
game what type of training did it take
for you which is big mess today
well I lost three bullet games actually
um and then also I I played a bunch this
weekend and I lost 200 ratings so it was
going re the practice was going great
um however I still think I should be
fine uh so I think I think I'll be fine
for the rest of the tournament I think
we'll be all right
well uh c-dog just a quick question
about your chess Journey overall who
taught you chess and uh can you tell us
like when you fell in love with it and
what appeals to you most about just the
process of playing chess
uh I think my dad told me chess when I
was
like 10 or 9 right something very young
uh so young that I can't remember
anything uh which is actually
surprisingly late in life uh but I I
really liked it I got really into it I
just like games and my parents wouldn't
let me play Pokemon for more than like
an hour so they were like are you gonna
play The Bold game because I guess
that's for small people so I played that
and then I was doing okay and I I played
a little bit competitively as a kid uh
but then I realized that I had to study
openings and I was out I was I've that
lost kid me I was gone I remember we had
to practice end games and I was like I
don't oh man
yeah that's when I didn't really like
chess I'm sorry I know that's like the
whole thing you guys got to do but
that's where I kind of stopped like
stopped enjoying the game
end games end games suck I think we're
all on the same page here I had like a
it was like a it was like a scene out of
a Christian Christopher Nolan film it
was like a I had like an eight-year-old
British man who put like the porn and
the king in front of us and then it was
just a king and if you moved the wrong
thing he would slap the piece across
like you've lost you've lost and you'll
never be a chess player it was like that
it's kind of dreadful dramatic it was
he was definitely he's seen some stuff
wow maybe that was Oppenheimer himself
telling you telling you those words
crazy
hey you never know they hide and play
they hide and play in sight but uh that
was an amazing match you're in the
Champions bracket and uh we know you
have a lot of preparing to do so you
know we will let you go it's really late
where you are and uh
right now
oh it's 8 A.M for a chess player 8 A.M
is like the worst time that's the only
one thing you should be doing at 8 am
yeah I have a question as well I wasn't
sure who to ask this for so for the
Finals should I book my flight now or
should I do that was just talking
handling that should I do that now just
just get out of the way just
outside the rates are cheaper right now
I think it's better to ask yeah I think
chess.com will be better too to let you
know yeah I appreciate that
dog
no problem at all
well thank you cdog we appreciate uh the
interview have a good one and best of
luck in the Champions bracket
I mean I mean Sea Dog
thank you thank you see you guys
all right so that was Sea Dog VA the
winner of group a and if you just join
us we have one more match for you with
the most obscure streamer they saved the
worst for last and the lowest viewed
streamer for last that would be xqc of
course yes I'm being sarcastic and he
will be taking on squeaks xqc not his
first rodeo in the POG Champs he is a
veteran he plays chess so consistently
on his stream uh Canty and we're just
used to associating one of the top
streamers the most popular streamers in
the world with chess how cool is that oh
that helps us out a lot of course they
get to see that oh chess oh this was
chess like this one they don't thought
chess was like watching grass grow like
my sister says so of course you know
chess is a very fun game or can be when
you have people like of course ourselves
you got Danny here you got xqc and you
have all the likes of the other
streamers and Paul Champs five all these
people coming together that actually
like chess as well and they're getting
better xqc big name liking chess we
gotta be winning there every time
xqc really needs not much of an
introduction other than to say that this
is his fourth pogchamp's appearance he
is the most experienced the most storied
pogchem's participant his very first
pogchamps game against Charlie well we
won't talk about that one I promise you
that but it's been all uphill since then
he's improved he's been consistent and
he loves chess that's the most important
thing obviously that is not the main
thing he does on stream but he's played
over 2500 games on chess.com and a lot
of them are streamed again hard to
overstate how much of a positive
influence xqc is for chess
100 I mean as you see he loves chess he
loves the game he spends a lot of time
on it we've seen him with of course uh
Levy Hikaru
um we've seen we've seen the clips of
him him in chess this is a big thing
what is going on right now what is going
on right now it's very hard I feel like
this person lost the chess game
also
I think he needs to unpack his suitcase
because this is giving me a certain
remote form of anxiety yeah I mean it's
very angry we need to get him he had to
pause it right there we don't know why
he was getting closer to the camera
there you know we just need to this is a
family channel guys okay just remember
that all right
while xqc's opponent is in front of you
that is squeaks he is not the strongest
player in POC James but again you know
you just have to take these ratings with
a grain of salt he is one of the best
Super Mario players he currently holds
167th Place in Mario 64 speed runs he is
a newer streamer but he's already
amassed well over a hundred thousand
followers he is not a pushover and xqc
is erratic right when he plays well he
can find some incredible moves he can
impress hikaranakamura but when he plays
poorly James we know that XTC is capable
of some big mistakes what is the xqc who
will arrive to this final Pock Champs
match of day five today what do you
think which xpc will we see well that's
the X Factor in fact is what is going to
see what happens
yeah you know look I am you know My
Brother's Keeper as Dania it says I I am
my brother right so all right uh but
with that being said of course the x is
gonna have to bring his game his best
game here to really try to win this it's
the two games anything can happen as
we've seen before we've seen upsets you
know we've seen people very upset right
so it does happen here blunders will
happen but whoever is making that last
Wonder or capitalizes on that last
funder it's going to be the winner of
the match
he has one of the top Grandmasters of
the 20th century savelli tartagaur said
the person who wins the chess game is
the one who makes the second to last
mistake of course person makes the last
mistake loses so it's about who makes
the second to last blunder because it's
only a two-game mini match if you're
just joining first of all you came at a
great time you came for the final match
featuring the top most popular streamer
on Twitch xqc playing a two-game match
with a Time control of 10 minutes per
side and a 5 Second increment if the
match is tied we've had exactly one of
those tied matches today then the
tiebreaker is contested over a three
minutes plus five second increment time
control and the game is drawn then they
continue to play until a winner is
declared but most of the matches that we
watch are fairly lopsided and not
lopsided in terms of the initial
strength but they generally go in one
player's favor that's what I found you
rarely get the sort of they start
exchanging sort of thing generally one
player seizes the momentum and sticks
with that momentum until the until the
end of the match with some exceptions
well I always like to leave it up to the
chat we always like to get it from the
chat chat is either 500 Hilo or 5500 ELO
there's never you know there's no in
between so chat who do you have is it
xqc which is squeaks who is going to win
who do you have let's get those in the
chat right now it's time the last
matchup of the day who do you put on
this line here who's on the line what
are you going for
I'm curious what we're gonna see from
um from squeaks uh how is he gonna play
in the openings did he cram kind of like
fusely because xqc he's been pretty
consistent in his opening repertoire so
you can prepare against him and that
gives you a major boost even at lower
levels if you get a comfortable position
out of the opening you put the right
position in place it gives you that
slight cushion right when you get that
Advantage out of the opening right and
of course it makes you feel better of
course but as we've seen you know in the
last matchup even with Frank having a
nice Vienna position basically like a
plus two off the opening was fail to
convert so of course it is not always
about your openings guys but it can't
help to have better positions to be able
to convert if you have a better position
coming out of the opening very possible
of course you got to pay attention to
those tactics and the checks captures
and threats hopefully they're both
paying attention to that now in the
rating wise I think xqc has a big rating
difference there but as we saw before in
one of the matches actually ghastly
being way underrated was able to take
down version doing that match so it is
important to understand that rating is
only a thing let's see if squeaks is
going to be higher rated than is what
his rating says
we will see and we can look into his
stream as we wait for the players to get
settled the game should begin
momentarily but here is squeaks's stream
he's just sort of chilling
and he's waiting for the game to begin
himself but not because it seems calm
too talking to the chat but because all
music in the background choir
as their daughter more calming music
is that um it felt really that virtual's
playlist sitting there and he's like
right you know doing it goodbye stop
he's like hey how's school going how's
it
[Music]
sing us a tune
I can see you guys man he'll be singing
xqc I think is ready to play I'm also
looking at xqc stream he's switched to
the chessboard you know what that means
how's that oh the game has begun here we
go all right so it begins
that's exactly right and so it begins So
It Begins and so it began
so it beganith and there's you see gone
perfect wow he was here and he and he
wasn't E4 E5
ended noteth
with us it begineth with a knight of
three if an exclusive playeth the
scotcheth defenses but he switches to
the real Lopez if oh as they said as
Shakespeare once said th on everything
like crazy whoa we got a Roy though wow
Bishop B5 on the board here well we have
a picture down there we're gonna get xqc
back up there and oh there he is
there he is
150 Subs to the community and then
saying Hell if yeah if Shakespeare
that's exactly right now on stream it
was uh Sonic Fox was in the chat like
how many did you do a backflip on stream
I'm like yo 100 but I was talking about
I'm like when I'm streaming like because
I can't just do a backflip right here I
mean it's just you know if it don't work
well I don't want nobody you know you
got to call an ambulance because I'm
like done that before so you know we can
wait for that one but thanks for Sonic
Fox gifting to the community for now on
as I uh attempt to do a backflip I don't
know what's gonna happen but we gonna
see on my stream we actually we actually
had a Berlin believe it or not I this
definitely is the first Berlin that
we've had in park gym so far xqc
deviating from Mainline Theory and
taking on c16 95 very logical play and
I've noticed this about his chess in
general he is very good at being logic
goal right yes he blunders yes his whole
board awareness is sometimes lacking but
he tries to follow logic with his moves
and that can be a very powerful strategy
against newer players so
Bing Bang Boom it's Bing Bang Boom time
he's already taken upon any five and if
black recaptures on e4 the E file could
be a problem for one of the players
first player to get a heavy piece on the
e-file often times is the one who
benefits so Queen E2 looks like a very
strong move here shall we have a look at
xcc's stream let's do it next you see
streamer and a streamer himself playing
some chess let's take a look at what he
got to say here
he's good
is this gonna be bad bro yeah
well your moves nice oh will he protect
what upon
will here move or will he protect
not actually removal
remove the night practically
black is lost
very carefully to not lose anything here
come on remove the Knight
oh that's fine I got this
five squirts he's found
you're not good
and he's about to be disappointed you
are not good bro okay then you won't
distract the knights
but this is the Moment of Truth candy
because now if life moves tonight he's
gonna lose his Queen anyway
do not move the knife the knights
no he's gonna move it he's gonna move it
he's gonna move it bro he's totally
gonna move it he's gonna move the chat
what you think Knight F6 oh my goodness
hit him splitting that's a Family
Channel
it's done
pretty fit
Bang
discover
that is such a worthwhile construction
to remember for newer players not just
any discovered check but the Knight also
guards the E7 Square so black literally
just loses the queen outright
this game is over unless we get
something cataclysmic
that's a I mean how do you even spell
that one first off from Donya there uh
of course Dania with the big words he
always liked that we always get some
nice vocabulary from Dania there
definitely very nice there but this
one's just GG I was gonna say the least
game over of course you got a block with
some we take in the queen and that is
over I mean look I haven't even
developed really my back rank yet I'm
going to Castle play rookie one
go crazy very nice from xqc this one I
have an interesting question for you
do you think and I don't know the answer
but do you think anybody's ever resigned
in a Pog Champs game wow you would think
the answer is yes but I actually think
the answer might be no you know what I
think based off of as much as we've I've
seen POG Champs I actually do think no I
was like thinking no because they play
every game out and they got the stream
and they watching and they're with you
know the chat they're streaming it right
but wow yeah they said they did
yesterday Frank resigned earlier so Chad
says that this happened daily dose has
to as well interesting right oh man
squeaks is Liz the wheels are coming off
and again this is the Golden Rule of POG
Champs one blunder leads to another
leads to another and he's already up a
full Queen is xqc he's also hunting for
more pawns here the well he'll convert
this without any problems and time
management has been great as well
let's see where squeaks is at mentally
like how is he handling the loss of all
his pieces
Free Pawn
but if I move my knight back he takes
this
I can trade it no he will not you know
what sorry to break it too
I like that
uh we have to have a bailout
I like that I think he's resigned
apparently thanks Chad I still feel
sorry
the same thing I still believe I like
that I like that when you learn more in
Chester then you know a lot of that
sucks to like my belief is like a
regular
thing you realize
your time is better spent not playing a
certain position yeah you resign more in
fact
okay he's thinking okay that pawn on D5
yes menacing
looks like he's not
upset you know I think he's come to
terms with the loss of equipment he
knows that xcc is one of the more
experienced players I think he's just
trying to last as long as he can
yeah definitely I mean just to have some
dignity there too as well and then lose
super quickly
yeah
um
okay where is he gonna go with his
Knight
good question there he's like we're
going to chat Chad is not gonna let me
go for that one I just know it you know
which one's not slipping through the
cracks that I never mind moving on wait
what happened Moving On Moving On Moving
On no I didn't say anything
wow okay tell me read the channel let me
see what y'all talking about
no but
it's at least at least a once per
commentary as xqc situates his Knight on
D5 you know what's a cool idea here I'm
looking at this Rook on f8 and it's
trapped and it's important to make
observations and then transform these
observations into concrete ideas so you
could say well how can I reinforce the
attack on this Rook then you can say
well what pieces allow me to attack that
Rook the only piece is the bishop then
you say well where does the bishop have
to be to be attacking that rook and you
say well this diagonal what's the most
efficient way of getting the bishop
there it's to play B3 and Bishop to A3
and there's actually very little the
black can do about this plan or Bishop
D2 and Bishop to B4 I'd be very
impressed if xcc finds this I think
instead he'll probably end up taking
this knight uh taking this Pawn
yeah he probably will take the pawn
there or even rookie one set something
up here really I mean it's just Choice
it's a matter of of choice here now at
this point the hard pocket part was
really kind of done already out of the
opening with the Queenie two he found
the right setup it's calculating as you
can see and yeah taste upon
watch enough of his games let's take a
look let's see where he's at in his
conversions
think
these things
okay what else
take
yo
he actually said it yeah let me think
about this yeah
yeah Daniel's lost a lot of excuses let
me think about this
okay hold up
hello
opinion
what is he doing
okay
Bank take
oh okay that's a new one that's new an
x-ray check it checks is G5
that's fire they think in the head he
like after our take is gonna be checked
wait whoa there's a great Russian
expression the compass is what xqc is
doing right now it's called the killing
ants with a cannonball it's when you're
way over complicating a process I mean
it's understandable just play a foreplay
Bishop don't sack anything when you
don't need to sack anything I learned
that expression okay the story behind it
is too convoluted but use that
expression you're welcome that is good
right killing ants with a cannonball
I love Expressions where you don't need
to explain the meaning at all it's like
immediately clear what it's referring to
and excuse me I would play here
and open up the king side anything
Bishop G5 F4 K H1
oh my God yeah that was the best that's
amazing because it's last a bishop is
white and my my king is on uh greenness
for the rest of the game I don't have to
every word about uh getting diagonal
checked by anything it's done he has no
tools to diagonal check so this this as
well as long as my files or whatever you
call that my my columns Excel sheets for
cheap uh
this is something that is very important
for late game
xcc is basically playing a Flawless game
now obviously he won the queen in the
opening but he has made no serious
mistakes at all in the conversion stage
100 didn't hang anything saw everything
most things played very well here this
could be a very high accuracy game
um besides obviously a few things maybe
85 percent something that
indeed and I think it's cool that xcc
has slowed down a little bit in the
opening which was a big big problem of
his in the past like the first five
seven moves there was often a blunder
here
he's forcing himself to take a little
bit longer double checking and that's
eliminated a lot of his blunders I think
he's underrated honestly at 9 44. and I
think he's got a shot to be 11 1200 at
the least at the very least of course
and he's also probably working behind
the scenes to the tool as well right
it's just because the rating says that
doesn't mean that he can't just you know
put it up another notch here a lot of
times you do see that I mean even again
upset earlier with ghastly and virtual
there was a huge rating difference and
gassy was able to pull it off very
possible here uh yeah this man xqc has
got it all under control here will he
see the hanging Bishop though
um
I'm trying to Hey try to understand what
he's calc he's probably I feel like he's
gonna play Queen G3
I don't know why
if he plays Queen G3
yeah it's because he was thinking about
it earlier and he takes the bishop look
at that okay wow he finds it vedemas
yes yes yes yes we
yes yes
is Sheikh
issue
yeah this is
over yes Red Rover over town population
squeaks
everything um
all right back we go to xqc Let's watch
him finish this one off
great job
I was not ready to Checkmate because it
says two Rooks which can cause check
meter as long as I have a a good
sacrifice I give you somewhere to move a
piece so I'll get to it I'm chilling and
even if I do before 15 I could lose like
what like even if I was my queen and it
went for free I still win the game so it
doesn't matter
displacement
um I'm still good to go
exactly bro
[Music]
it is
G5 and a ladder mate okay
move check move checkmate
beautiful that's literally or I would
move the queen back first so Queen G3
might make an appearance after all you
can't decide which place
it's okay I'm waiting we're waiting
somebody's annoying me let him Rook let
me think about this
letting Rook chat Lighting World breathe
quiet silence chat letting Rook killing
ants with the Cannonball
I think G6
and he wants queen G3 black doesn't have
to take the Rook technically yeah and
you could you could do that
um
how to check he's just gonna take let
him Rook he's working right now he's
working
Rook H6 is made in two I think no not
made in two but oh it is made in two I
protected queen of four queen queen F4
wow that's really pretty actually
yeah
Queen G3 also winning I can prep
Checkmate three
I can pepper checkmates
that would be nice
I mean I like the board Vision though
check iMovie
board Vision out here
I think he wants to put the queen on G5
so he's
yeah Queen C5 is viable of course I'm
gonna go here defense double double lead
to Montreal both pawns perfect Checkmate
and I'll prepare for a possible assault
on the bottom
with the wet pieces black and amount
this assault
a man
is calculating
and one plus inbound
does that it's like M3 Plus or whatever
what does that mean M3 plus yeah
yeah we're learning some new chest terms
it could work when G5 mate right Bang
boom there it is
let's go one zero that was smooth I mean
that was over after he won the queen to
be fair
so a good fight by squeaks but he had
zero chances down a full Queen xqc
converting with room to spare
100 sqc was in great form there he was
able to just finish this off very fast I
mean he from the opening up the piece up
the queen easy easy game for xqc now
he's gonna add a black pieces squeaks is
gonna have to try to make something
happen here with the white pieces maybe
move a little faster too as well and
just you know have some confidence
hopefully he goes well for him but xqc
is in great form right now
he really is he's confident and we've
talked about this through most of the
broadcasts but I really can't stress
enough four times in POG Champs he knows
the routine right he knows what it feels
like squeaks still kind of getting the
hang of things but for xqc it's another
day in the office and that's exactly how
you want to treat these tournaments you
don't want to put too much pressure on
yourself or pretend that this is the
most important game you played you want
to play this like you play normal Blitz
Games and that's the sense that I'm
getting from xqc not to mention that his
openings are very Advanced he's had so
many lessons with icaro he's just
consumed probably the most chess content
of anybody in the field arguably
um James as the second game about to get
underway
yeah second game comes in underway you
get the black pieces here I'm confident
so I'm feeling confident I'm just about
to do my thing here if I'm xqc it's
another day in the office as you
mentioned right excuse easy check in
close now like unbelievable she's
playing check Clips I don't see the
chess.com tab though so this you realize
the second game yes he does okay there
we go
okay let's get this underway
and we got this underway
now what does xcc play against D4 do you
remember
because I don't know I don't he might
have even changed it too as well um but
I'm not familiar with what he plays
only five standard very easy okay
so xqc played a real Lopez in the
previous game with white will squeaks
copy the master now xkc used to play the
scotch and we have an Italian from
squeaks
Italian game so far so good xqc thinking
really difficult really hard there in
the zone trying to recall some Theory
here
looks around I wonder if he'd probably
look at another screen yeah that's the
screen look check the screen okay now
what do I play Knight of six Knight G5
that leads to the fried liver I never
knew why it was called the fried lover
but that is what it's called one of the
oldest openings in existence
um James the fried liver has been known
literally since the time of Rue Lopez in
the 1500s wow still play today
which is pretty staggering and Rue Lopez
fun fact
we associate him believe it or not with
the real Lopez right Bishop B5 but he
actually was the first he invented the
king's Gambit Rue Lopez in his book from
I think 1562 was the first chess author
to mention E4 E5 F4 so the king's Gambit
could also be referred to as the Ray
Lopez wow that is crazy Dania here with
the the knowledge guys the history I
remember watching dying strange time on
the Howard Staunton thing with the
letter I'm like wow that was crazy it
was like an hour of history from Dania
it's all history
also interesting first time fried lever
was played in OTB game 1610 by Julio
palario who was an Italian player
considered the strongest player of the
early 1600s so
400 years of theory and it's all allowed
xqc to play the race but squeaks punters
is a knight and let's check into his
stream he's confused the move order
yeah it's a tough one you can't confuse
that one
and if he takes the Knight it's already
over here guys
[Music]
oh my god I'm an idiot dude I'm such a
I'm such an idiot dude I dude I can't
believe a feeling we can all relate it's
a stupid position
now it's not over you can take D5 and
Lex King is still pretty open
yeah correct you can still transpose I
guess well I mean 985 you don't have to
yeah that's the issue it's not the end
of the world don't tilt James the the
rule of POG chimp you remember what it
is right you blunder one piece and you
bloom
everybody just put F's in the chat we
need to you know hugs man hey just bring
it in Big Dog one time you need some
love honestly it's gonna it hurts it
hurts does he realize that I don't think
he's just like locked into the fact that
he just wanted another piece
[Music]
that hurts that definitely hurts there
and you got the sad music in the
background yeah yeah for full effect
yeah change the music
xqc just trying to trade all the pieces
take the Knight on C3
and trade Queens which is I want to take
away this one let's say with this one it
opens up the bishop okay but it allows
the queen trade
yeah he just I'm mopping up everything
man you see not even thinking
this is just easy clap get the bishop
out put a rook on d8 it moves
play themselves
yeah yeah this is going to be longer
though because Queens are off which is
uh
squeaks here but I mean sqc didn't even
I mean he's not even down time here so
it is a very difficult game
unfortunately the Fright liver did not
go squeaks away I had the right
intention the right few moves
but not the right execution
Knight takes F7 of course is a move but
after you trade on D5 it's a very famous
night sacrifice which is why black is
not supposed to recapture on D5 it
happens you're newer to chess you don't
have the moves solidly in your mind and
so you confuse the move order it happens
this was fun and didn't uh Donya so you
know it's fry liver right it's somebody
in the chest say a raw liver that was a
raw liberal instead of a fried liver
guys that was an uncooked liver that was
uncooked night on F7 okay xqc should
bring
chest Flawless man
finding everything up
okay let's go back to xqc stream
Rook C1 nice
so you know that situation especially
OTB where you have a complicated moment
you calculate a lot of lines and then
you basically forget what you calculated
at the start and you think wait a second
that move is kind of cool without
realizing that you've already refuted
and rejected the move and you end up
playing it anyway because you literally
forgot that you had already looked at it
at the start of your thinking time very
common type of blunder
Mary common here and xqc is closing this
one out to oh it looks like time is
about even
convincing in the first convincing in
the seconds here
great showing from xqc everybody wanted
to see this of course but it was also
squeaks fans just wanted to see him do
well here not still going game is still
going but definitely really making him
making him squeaks
right making them squeaks Chad you hear
that I mean for hour five it's not not
the worst pun hopefully I can be
forgiven oh yeah yeah we had some great
ones excellent ones today from Dania
okay so move the bishop don't forget to
do that
the overthinking it a little bit I think
he's terrified of losing C7 so if I know
xqc I feel like he'll
get the get the hankering to play Knight
defun now he played Bishop D3
realizing that I've never thought about
this I've already thought about this man
yeah don't duplicate your thoughts
come on
Bishop takes E7
rookie 8 rookie two is coming let's see
if xqc figures out the right most
efficient winning setup here
what you got here it is
poorly chat I I I I I'm disappointed I
didn't play this properly at all
you sound like a cover bro he's getting
in his head right now I'm gonna click on
the way with this interaction without
any like bad trades you know
I'm a I fumbled it like what am I
doing what am I doing Bongo there's
still a complete bungle that Chad just
like bungle why it's usually before she
sleep Bongos complete Bunch totally
bundled it
uh
completely waiting too
Rook C8 his submission he's infant mine
we talk skip man again oh and Benny also
gets a check take no I think we thought
about this three times
The Rook I gotta stop it's never gonna
get past just the two horses guarding D7
and the King guarding E7 doesn't have to
worry about white shark getting to D7
it's like that I tried to steal
spaghetti from a shop
there was a security guard and I
couldn't get pasta
how did he come up with these problems
Wait no that's not mine that I think
that won the awards
oh really
and I guess probably just reads these
bro on 101. he's reading the boys every
day maybe uh
my dad has suggested that I register for
a donor card he's a man after my own
pawns up it's fine that was second place
[Laughter]
squares because his last diagonals are
all on black squares
all his remaining diagonals are on black
squares and use white squares instead
gotcha
that way if I break this thumb to my
head oh wait where you get to discover
right here he gets Discovery
that's a rook xkc that is wait capture
yeah I think it might be time to resign
uh
is it time to resign resign
button
yeah
[Laughter]
never resign
man you do here
can you have two and there are no pieces
left for a squeaks besides the bishop
here
excuse me the Flawless performance today
yeah what really was not even close
Joe says nothing getting past to him
that's funny
yeah never nothing wrong
it is honestly just a lopsided match-up
and and squeaks has shown some grasp of
fundamentals you know opening moves but
just too many one move wonders he needs
to clean up some of that of course in
this game Knight takes F7 really set the
tone and just so hard to survive an
initial blunder like that and stabilize
yourself mentally for any player of any
level
so yeah you shouldn't feel bad
exactly right he played and he also
playing somebody who actually practices
a lot I think it's 2500 games plus you
know right you know and Counting xqcs uh
definitely working on the game a lot
more that experience pays off
for sure and excuse you really taking
his time here I I feel like he just
should just get down to business take
some of these puns on the queen side and
promote one of his many passers that
he's about to create making sure that
nothing
gets away that he doesn't hang anything
a little bit more positional now but I'm
just a easy conversion
indeed a lot of extra pieces
pretty long conversion by xqc if
anything wins King E6 Rook D3 but we
talked about it I think this is one of
the biggest struggles for beginner to
intermediate players is they they feel
like there's only one path I think when
I was coaching Charlie that was his
problem it was that he who he would be
up two Rooks and I would just tell him
you can do anything literally anything
would just make a move by the way I'm
passant wins the game immediately and
SEC missed it but he would get it in his
head that there was one most efficient
path and he had to sit there until he
found it and that's why he starts
floundering and going back and forth
push C2 go Rook D1 really anything at
all that you want
yeah definitely many ways to win it here
he wants to be very cautious which is
understandable the win is here one win
away sometimes the nerves get there but
he is just up a lot of material here
it's gonna take a lot to lose this game
and it's just not possible to lose this
game just doesn't show possible at all
from it's how what we saw from squeak so
far
there's your B6 Rook D2 check
yeah
okay time for squeaks to consider
hitting that button you know you know
what that button would be
hit the button
hit a button you can even go C2 as well
you don't even have to move the Rook
Knight A5 Knights on the rim are amazing
Daniel 2023 Knights on the rim are
amazing
well they're not on the room anymore but
let's check into squeaks maybe one last
time to see how he's you know dealing
with the experience of losing this game
he's doing it with some Vivaldi great
idea yeah music's nice
I assume that's Vivaldi but it might be
Bach or somebody else
very nice like very soothing like a
glass of wine and just I have a good
time relax this is not relaxing at all
here he takes because
it is
the Noose
[Music]
I mean take the Rook not take the Rook
doesn't change anything
it's Rossini good to know
I totally knew that
it's a little palm squirrel it's a
little bump okay all right nice all that
one coming
do one great move the bishop is
dominated by the Knight on C4 couldn't
get pasta
oh man that is funny today that pasta
Bishop E3 only safe move
or you can just king take C4 it doesn't
matter here
there's another safe move starts with R
um
and ends with design
or hit in Bhutan yeah
hit Level done
hello toys
okay excuse me greedy keeping all of us
and keeping all of his loot here
he's like yeah
I'm up three pieces and about the queen
one
everything is defended by everything The
Rook defends the pawn which is defended
by the Knight which is defended by the
other Knight which is protecting the
pawn on B7 the most important Pawn on
the board
yeah this is right oh yeah wow squeaks
is trying to get his own Queen there
without that pawn white would have won
because he would have had connected
passers oh man those connected bastards
win every time Chad even if you down
three pieces
yeah yeah I think squeaks is gonna be
upset at how he lost the game so
although by the way C2 is inaccurate
because you're gonna have a hard time
moving away The Rook while giving away
without giving away the seatbon in fact
I don't think there's a good way to do
that
you should just move the rook and get a
say yeah that's the easiest thing to do
here easy easy
this is crazy
shall we go back to xqc maybe finish off
watch him finish off the game absolutely
yeah he's gonna make a queen this is
going to be fast
Godzilla what is this Arrow yeah what is
that did you see that damn
girl what
oh yeah Checkmate in one on D2 well
right no stalemates there are three
pawns there still as well
check always in the Trap at home well
yep rookie one mate
hold up rookie he literally hovered over
that square rookie one is made no
oh my gosh Rook A2 and queen A1 is
Ladder made fancy chicken coming in
literally it is possible to not mate
here okay too oh
straightforward I think there we go
I like that remix
it's a two-piece spicy
that's a two-piece spicy from xqc
it is indeed xqc has done it he's one
two zero in the most convincing fashion
of anybody uh that we saw today it was
not even close and xkc's big experience
level four years of POG Champs really
comes in handy today for squeaks it's
his first year he's a newer player he'll
use this experience and he will get
better but that's just the way it goes
sometimes these matches can be very
lopsided absolutely of course I mean as
you see like as you see that experience
just pays off 2500 plus games hanging
you know mini POG Champs been with uh
left even with Hikaru scene chess
content been a part of Chess content
he's gonna do well right but of course
uh it's not the last you'll see from
squeaks and squeaks has done well so far
as well so I mean we'll see what happens
in the rest of it here but again
congrats to xqc there that was big for
him and squeaks has been playing well
thus far he featured he's got four
points but xqc is on the move of course
tyler1 has been in a league of his own
he's been Unstoppable both in terms of
his games and in terms of his reaction
so a lot remaining to be disputed here
in group C but we just have a lot of
experience in pogchamps five and I feel
like the experienced players are just
consistently doing better because
they're able to quell the Jitters they
have more training under their belts and
they're just better chess players this
is what happens and that comes from
training of course and doing lots of
training and working and sometimes
getting a little bit lucky but you get
luckier when you have the training there
wow so xqc with the dub two oh that was
nice well folks we have the ultimate
treat we will of course have xqc in the
studio for an interview you will not
want to miss it as pogchamps day five
starts to come to an end stay tuned
we'll have xqc for an interview in just
a couple moments
oh yeah
[Music]
for uh for for 10 seconds yeah yes yes
why to play and drop
oh but this this I'm pretty sure I've
seen
this looks so familiar
so he has to go to either H2 H3 I
haven't been able to decide which one
but my three seconds pass fast yes yes
yes my feeling would be
definitely not H2 because H2 then maybe
e one night that's really a problem yes
so I have to go to H3 H3 Knight f4h2 my
G4 check
then kh1 Knight F2 Chuck
very good
I know this one I'm just trying to
remember
so it's when the three nice but it's a
king H3 Knight F4 Knight or uh
King H2 Knight G4 Chuck Knight G4 King
H1
yeah very good
um okay let's
start with King H2
kind of have to like this
um H2O would probably go E1 I
oh is this case of E1 light then Knight
F3
well yes but King H3 I will go Knight F4
okay now I have to go to H2 Knight G4
okay now I have to go to H1 Knight F2
okay King H2 E1 light
and uh
married to it
oh Knight F3 Knight g33 yeah
yeah Knight F3 Knight takes a three King
G3 very nice
any of this one I was just trying to
remember the whole detail look you're
the only one that's uh remaining perfect
after
five studies last one
no I've seen this one okay this one I
think I've seen before Queen G7 remember
seven Knight six yes
but what's the uh what's the puzzle why
the move
was you you saved the simplest one for
last one this this is crazy
yes yes
wow
how did you get me here
so Queen G7 or K7 Knight P6 made yeah
yes that's it we saved the easiest for
Less
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the conclusion of day
five of pogchamps 5 in front of you
there the victor of our final match xqc
wins his match 2-0 against squeaks and
xqc is joining us as is his opponent in
the studio for an interview we
appreciate it congratulations xqc first
question you are the veteran of veterans
when it comes to pog shims this is your
fourth appearance how much does that
help you retain your confidence it felt
like you had everything under control
from the beginning do you lean on all
that experience as you play
yeah um I've been playing a lot of like
uh solo chess online right and to me it
feels like uh when I'm playing POG
Champs everybody's got at least some
sort of coaching or they know at some
sort of a game plan and I realize that a
lot of people have to do is worry about
the early opening cheeses and to develop
like early opening like book plays and
once I'm past that I think my game since
it's pretty good I can just play the
game uh from Instinct and win because
last time okay there was um the six
moves okay from um
uh I will remember we're not gonna talk
about it we're not talking about it okay
the six moves that I lost last time from
the uh Scholars mate I get it that's one
of the opening cheeses as long as I
focus on not losing at that point
I'm good to go and I think I think
you build because whatever I want I play
way way above my rating in uh in late
game and mid game as long as I I started
the early game so I felt confident that
all the way through after the early game
very nice uh congratulations xqc and
squeaks may I use playing he was in
there he was doing your things but with
that fried liver there oh man we saw the
pain just to move order difference there
could have went definitely another way
especially if we were able to take the
pawn instead what happened in that
little blip there of course it seemed
like you were prepped he was ready but
then Knight takes F7 happened what tell
us a little bit about that a little bit
about your prep coming into today's
month
yeah Jimmy just like xqc said I got the
coaching done I tried my hardest I had a
plan and I wasn't able to execute so in
all honesty I'm pretty bummed out uh I
think xqc played an amazing game I'm
very proud uh but uh yeah I just got
nervous
um and unfortunately I was unable to
execute I guess experience really did
Trump uh you know the new guy
talking of trump is that a wig on your
head
uh yeah actually yeah last time I did an
interview the chess CEO made fun of my
hairline so I just wanted to cover my
bases
you know what I mean
I have to compete with you xqc I mean my
hair would look even more barren
all right
it is what it is unlucky rule for me
um xqc you have a long career playing
chess uh getting taught by the greatest
including Hikaru what keeps you coming
back what is the aspect or aspects of
Chess that you love the most when you
play
um I'm gonna be honest with you I just
wanna I just wanna
be people who's put like as much time as
I did because I think that when you're
competing against people of your rank
right if you guys are playing chess and
you're trying to go up in the world of
Chess it's different than this because
you know how much hours will it put in
there right whatever that Express I I
don't I don't feel good about it okay I
I want to be somebody who was who's put
as much time but I learned faster
okay so no disrespective but
um this is why I come back is that I
want to measure my skill and uh learning
uh pace and um last time I got a bit
disappointed I only came back because
last time that I came into this I got
really disappointed in my performance it
was terrible okay I got moved in six and
there's been like so many videos about
it I enhancement at night so it's been
years and I still lose sleep on it feel
my family for it and I'm here for
Redemption and I'm gonna get it
oh
sorry I was just gonna say you know uh
it's a good point from xqz but frankly I
think like I wish I wish we could play
another where we were able to put in the
Reps because I seriously think that I
can surprise you you know if I didn't
make that mistake in the beginning I
think it would really be a totally
different story between us Matt yeah is
this a a match on the line boys is that
what we're saying right here I agree
with swax about what he's saying right
now
you can spend as much time as you want
to a pricing it will never beat me
anyway oh my God you played a really
good xqbz really good really good
wow I love it I love the banter here boy
sqc how do you feel about your match
coming up Tyler won more like Tyler you
know two right now man he's playing
really good
uh toddler two foot yeah he's done I
mean he has always no chance the guy's
like I think the guy's sub 100 rated and
I said it before I think if you reach a
rating he's at I think you should be
banned from playing the game I think as
an as an adult if you play that bad the
system should should say that you're not
you're not even trying to win the game
and you're ruining the expense of other
people he's so bad
I'm sorry elevation have been allowed
him yeah I think it's just that bad
man I can't wait for this to be settled
tomorrow James I don't know if you can
oh man can't be watching all day
he said I'm gonna Rook him wow well we
appreciate your your confidence and your
honesty and you have talked the talk or
you've walked the walk times 100 xqc
your accuracy was in the 90s both games
today so it was really fun to watch your
conversion was smooth and uh we will let
you continue your stream and rest up and
prepare for tomorrow's grudge match
against Tyler thank you I'll see you
guys then I'll see you guys there yeah
I'll see you in your room tomorrow all
right guys take care thanks for the
invite and uh bye
bye-bye good luck thank you my thank you
squeaks thank you xqc
have a good rest of your stream guys
well that was that James I think he said
everything that needed to be said as we
look at the standings here across all
four groups xqc determined to depose
tyler1 that is for sure
yeah not even just Amy xqc's like bring
anybody I don't care who it is I mean we
heard that from Frank too as well we
like Frank who you want to play You're
like I don't care who I played put him
in front of me loving the energy the
animosity look at all the emotions here
it's a lot this is Paul Champs five very
competitive as we see these creators
take each other on and it's exciting
every single time
and that's the whole point of POG ships
that was the initial concept right it's
yes friendly everyone's nice to each
other but when push comes to shove if
the players aren't competitive then it's
not fun if mean if winning doesn't mean
the most of anything to them then why
are we playing the tournament so this is
the fighting spirit that we come here
for him this is what we look for and
this is what we got in today's matches
James I'll pass it back to you one more
time
I think we got the excitement and the
action that we were looking for today
times a hundred absolutely of course I
mean Paul exams reached all area were
really big areas of Chess where of
course A lot of people are rated around
the same maybe a little higher maybe a
little lower rated to get to see how
they play some of your favorite creators
that you've watched in all types of
Chess or all types of just YouTube
content whatever you consume of course
you're able to see that with these
players here the emotions and the fun
and the excitement and blunders and also
high accuracy games especially xqc
coming back with a vengeance here and
having nightmares about the old stuff
that happened years ago as he said it
motivates him it's nice to see amazing
to see it and uh and I'm amazing amazed
to be here especially with you Diane my
guy on the chat too as well love y'all
it was great likewise James this was
amazing and there will be more amazing
coming your way tomorrow daily dose of
amazing in fact we'll start at noon
Pacific 3 P.M eastern time with virtual
taking on daily dose of internet and
then one hour later Papa plot will take
on foosli with daily dose and fousey
still trying to get on the board they
will be returning with a Vengeance and
then to round off the day cutie
Cinderella against I did a thing The
Confident Australian and xqc tomorrow
takes on genity and of course in the
Champions bracket if he can make it he
will very likely face Tyler one in The
Grudge Match that we are all waiting for
and finally it'll be cutie Cinderella
um against foosli to round off the day
at 7 pm Eastern so plenty of matches
plenty of action that is coming your way
tomorrow and before we wrap up wanted to
remind you of uh one more thing which is
that if you're a bullet Aficionado and
if you're looking to put your bullet
chess skills to the test weekly you can
now compete in the community bullet
brawl Arena and win Diamond membership
anyone is eligible to throw their hat in
the ring and prove their speech as
prowess all you have to do is join the
Community Club on chess.com and register
for the arena use x Glam CBB that's
ex-gram Charlie Billy Bob in chat for
all the details make sure to hop into
the community bullet brawl weekly and on
that note
James it's been a very long day it's
been an exciting day but I for one am
exhausted and I think people in the chat
are too we hope you enjoyed the action
folks here on day five of pogchamps five
it was a pleasure and an honor to
commentate these celebs we will be back
with more action tomorrow but for now
have a great rest of your day
oh my goodness that hurts oh man oh my
God Anna your plan worth
[Music]
oh my God
oh my God that's not what I meant to do
oh yeah that's a wrap oh my goodness oh
Castle oh man he sees it he saw it
that was amazing
[Music]
there we go
all the way down
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
foreign